Dumb luck.
All right ladies,
gentlemen,
we're live.
We're live right now.
If you've never listened to
one of these things before,
this is not a regular podcast.
Don't expect some deep insight to the
nature of the universe or even rational
conversations because
there's alcohol involved.
There might be some weed.
I smoked some weed.
I Dunno.
There might have been weeding this room.
Uh,
and uh,
there's a,
a bunch of fucking savages to my left.
Eddie Bravo,
Eddie the motherfucking twister.
Bravo one of the baddest
dudes on the planet earth.
Thank you.
One of my favorite human
beings that's ever existed.
And Eddie Bravo to his,
to his left Justin Milo's trainer
Xtrordinair all throughout the lands.
You could find him on line at the,
what does it,
personal training.
Personal training.com handsome bastard.
Look at them.
Beautiful features,
very polite,
well-read.
Kyla B is in the fucking house.
Oh Shit.
UFC welterweight prospect bitches
fighting Eric Silva in March in Brazil,
going deep into the lion's den.
Doot,
doot,
caveman coffee it all up in this
bitch with the caveman coffee,
uh,
to his left,
the motherfucking CEO of caveman coffee.
Great Tait Fletcher.
Take the animal Fletcher,
take the savage Fletcher,
fill in the blank with the nicknames.
One of the,
again,
one of the baddest motherfucker,
several of caveman
coffee or I'm more of a,
one of the Fertittas Dana a little bit.
Now he's coming out and
before for us to push him out.
Is that what you're saying?
I think he's looking at you and go,
you know what I want to do with taking,
dude,
he's doing both.
Listen,
go ahead and call me Mister Fertitta.
I'd be happy to help.
Tate is always hustling.
Caveman coffee comes in.
Yeah,
we've got a microbrewery.
He hands me his fuck a beer.
I'm like,
dude,
you're making beer.
This is outrageous.
Has got to work in this
tape is always moving,
always moving.
There's no stillness with Tate Fletcher.
You will find no dust.
[inaudible] Brendan motherfucking Shaw,
possibly the funniest a UFC
fighter that's ever lived.
You might pick.
Yeah,
he's made me laugh harder.
Don't put,
don't put me in a sauna and
make me fuck my way out.
Is one of the great all time one liners.
It's ever been thought a huge
compliment on these podcasts.
Yeah,
he's funnier here.
Chuck jails,
one of the greatest trash
talkers funnier than rampage.
Yes.
Ooh,
yes,
he's fine.
You know what?
It's close.
Close.
But funny though.
He's not on purpose.
Funny.
Well it's also a Quinten
is more irritable.
Like shop's got a smoother personality.
Couldn't get mad if he got out.
Yeah.
The angry Quinten it,
you know Quinton's always thinking
everybody's ganging up on him.
We're about to watch the fights right now.
It's a,
how do you say this gentleman's name?
The first fight is,
we've got to sync this up so you guys
know we're watching the fights and doing
commentary sort of,
I mean,
we're not really doing commentary,
but we're watching the fights and
doing a podcast at the same time.
That's the idea behind these.
So if you're tuning into it,
if you're listening to it,
you might
want to just fucking ditch this one and
go back to one with some scientists.
Jolie one,
you can have micro science
says go find Joe Tate Fletcher,
my drop some signs up in this bitch.
But,
uh,
right now it's a Ray Borg is a
about about to fight this gentleman.
I don't know how to say his name.
Give us some volume there.
Young Jamie.
Chris Kull ladies set the dude's name.
Pow.
All right.
I'm taking the headphones off
so if shit gets out of control,
you've been warned.
Fights starting right now.
It's four minutes,
58 seconds if you want
to sync up four minutes.
58 seconds of the first round was on the
clock when I said that Mario Yamasaki
might be fucking mad at her.
Right for doing that shit taken his,
she still can't see Mario's heart.
I can't do that shit.
Did the heart that she did it.
It comes out that's been around.
It ain't his.
Yeah,
but he does.
He on it for the UFC does.
You can't,
you can't do that.
That's not going to talk
to that show round forever.
Do that.
Throw that shit on your car.
That means you're gay.
The rainbow,
that's different.
No,
but for the,
it's a UFC thing.
The camera's on you.
You got your thing.
You know,
like the CIC referee,
what's her name with the blonde hair?
She goes like this.
She goes,
no.
She goes like both.
But that's box and,
and she,
she could be the mills lane of a MMA,
but,
but if you're a octagon girl,
you gotta do something right.
You just can't wave y'all do something.
You know what Herb Dean,
he just calls whatever.
He was like,
he doesn't want it.
Everyone's like,
cause that's our moment.
The referee,
that's their moment where they're
in the spotlight right now.
You're going to do something,
Mario Yamasaki said,
fuck it.
I'm going to spread love.
That's my second Mac.
I do whatever I want.
Bruce Bumper does.
Fucking wheel kicks and shit.
You know what I mean?
Why not throw a little little uh,
hand size.
Never been a guy like Bruce buffer that
you could talk into doing a ThreeSixty
pretty agile.
He did a three 60 used to do the one 80.
We were all sitting there a fucking
three 60 it was the greatest thing ever.
We blew his knee out.
No,
no,
no.
He blows me out jumping.
He was jumping,
bro.
I've seen him in the gym with
cables doing the Bruce Buffer
resistance training and telling you why
he's doing it to fucking staring into
the gym.
I hear a commitment,
a hybrid in front of everyone,
like oh for sure relaxed man.
He's doing resistant bay.
You know what?
I bet a little spot for sure.
It'd be took a little cup of water and
that would help as well cause he's Kinda
doing copper wire.
So meanwhile,
not to be disrespectful to these gentlemen
that are engaging in mortal combat
right now.
Homeboy on top was a minus
1000 when's the last time saw?
It might it's 1000 what does that mean?
That means a,
he's a heavy favorite
to win the fight heavy,
heavy.
Favorite 1000 is like 10 to one right?
Is that what he was?
Who made these odds?
Sean Shelby.
I Dunno.
It makes it,
he wouldn't know.
Right?
Sometimes they're way off.
Dude,
I've,
I like tough to bed.
I've hooked Aubrey up a bunch of times
where I was like that line is crazy.
Like you got a guy coming
in from somewhere else and
people might not know and
the Vegas guys might have
never seen him fight before.
He like get the fuck
Outta here with this line.
This line is ridiculous.
You got to wonder who's making those.
They probably,
they're not too educated.
Yeah.
Like especially on the undercard is
there's been some ones in the past.
Oh,
like when Wonderboy Thompson was fighting
was he?
No,
it wasn't wonderful.
It was another Rick,
really good striker.
I'll remember as a punk.
And I mentioned Sean Shelby because
not because like he's an idiot.
Oh,
I only said that because he would,
he's the only one who would know
the thousand minus a thousand.
Like I don't know these guys,
I would just say it's even right.
But if you really know like Sha only
a guy like Shawn shelving studies,
these guys would go do
the bad guy's terrible.
And this other guys that are running,
who knows everybody.
Everybody in all the records.
Joe.
So Joe Silva,
no,
no one knows more about
MMA than Joe Sova Library.
No one knows more about.
Like he might not know
as much about execution,
like how to execute things
are where things are gone.
It's that funded as far as how many like
guys who know fighters and know who's
fighting and winning.
Joe Silva knows more than anybody.
No one to make your heart drop more
than when you on your cell phone,
you get a call from Joe Silva.
What does Joe Silva,
cause you know he's only
calling about matchups.
He's not comfort anything
right here on the cell phone.
You're like,
oh shit,
he's a smart dude.
And or her heart just start to race.
We can see just so right away sweat.
I've been trying to get Joe's hills on
the podcast for a while and I told them,
I go,
look dude,
how about we just don't talk about MMA?
Just,
we won't even talk about him in May.
Right?
Like he's a really smart dude,
but he's,
you know,
he's in a position as a match maker.
He has to be very careful.
You know,
I can't get them high and
have him talking crazy shit.
You know,
people don't have nowhere to live.
I don't know where he lives.
I don't know if they want it.
They publicly said,
I won't say it,
but I like that guy.
I liked Joe Silva a lot.
He's smart as fuck dude.
He gave me a Sam Harris' book
way back in the day before.
Like I'm friends with Sam Harris.
I found out about it through Joe.
Joe gave me a book,
letters to a Christian nation.
Great Book.
Wouldn't he liked to come on
like with the guy like that?
Just so he could talk
to a guy that he admires
triangle.
Oh,
up right there.
What would
suddenly,
yeah,
that's too late.
He's fine.
The got let go.
It's over.
You can tell the guy goes,
oh shit,
he's good.
You know.
You know what impressed me wasn't that.
You know what impressed me more than that?
Leo Vieira and you in Brazil when
he had locked that went up on you.
Why you got to bring up old shit
cause your defense is impeccable.
No,
no.
He almost,
I don't know what I was doing
the deep into what I held my
arm or something like this.
It was whatever it was.
I didn't know what I was doing
and I was about to tat he let go.
He gave me too much.
My face is purple.
It's one of those old like old TV footage.
It looks like an old Muhammad Ali type.
Just old,
but you could see my face is
purple where you got to go out.
When I was about to go out there and
then I didn't want to show any weakness,
so I stood up really quick and like I
got looking like I was going to shoot,
you're going to shoot,
but meanwhile I'm drunk as fuck.
He's scared that he's going
to see them that you know,
you just pretend like nothing's wrong.
I was like taking shots and shit.
Never taken a shot in my life and
never taking a shot at in my life.
But that's how purple my head was.
Ronda Rousey Cat Zingano
guys a call and I think it's MMA.
MMA Junkie Radio,
I think coined it.
They would call it Lilith fair because
the woman main event and a woman combien.
Really it is.
There's a co main event,
Holly Holly Holm,
striking Greg Kell paints in the chicken.
Put that girl.
Oh Gosh,
I want to see that.
Fuck yeah.
You know what?
Even though Weidman in
Belfort was that the match,
if there was canceled,
even though that,
that would have been
a great fucking match.
Any match said Weidman in any match.
That part is great,
but seriously,
I love watching Ronda cause
you know a million percent.
She's going to come after.
She's from the,
I think she gets hypnotized,
I think.
I think she's the only one
that's listening to Mike Tyson.
Mike Tyson told everybody,
everybody on Howard Stern,
he told everybody,
he said custom model was
really into hypnotizing me
at before every one of those
big fights in the day
I was sitting at ties.
He brought in a real witness.
He said because the model was actually
an amateur hypnotists himself,
but he brought in a real legit guy before
every fight they hypnotize shit and he
stopped getting into ties after customer
don't get its own to hit and tells me
how come no one's going shit,
how can learn?
Everyone's getting it straight.
The conditioning coach,
they're going to need it.
You get to coach a wrestling coach,
striking coach and a hypnotist
whose written the test dummies.
You know what I mean?
It's going to get to that point eventually
when people realize or as Mike Tyson
bat shit crazy.
Well,
you know what he said he was
hitting the ties in the locker room,
a professional hypnotist before
he went out the next week or what?
Doesn't it make sense?
You have to accept it
like if you're resistant.
We know Joe Schilling.
Schilling got a hypnotist now.
Vinny showtime shoreman.
Who is it?
Joe Shelley's upset.
Did you see that spinning
back fist right hand?
He dropped that dude with and glory.
Just set them up for the
right to perfect timing.
Relaxed cracks him up the open book.
Bam drops the right at the time.
Horn glory like a few fights ago
and there was the tournament,
right?
You watch those guys,
they're knocked
out four,
five times budget Naco that they keep
fighting all through to the finals.
Holy Fuck.
If you knew anything about kickboxing,
listen to this line up.
He fought in one fucking night fight.
Simon Marcus,
who was 39 and Oh,
okay.
Who had already knocked
him out in the past.
They go three fucking
round to a dead heat.
So they go to a fourth round.
This is the first fight he's got
to fight three times three murders.
Knock Simon Marcus out with a right hand,
puts them to sleep face
plants cause fucking chaos.
Then he fights Wayne Barrett to
do to also had beat him before.
Beats him by decision.
Barrett's a bad motherfucker.
Then he goes into the main
event and fights are Levin.
Who's if it shillings not
the best leavens the best.
It's like those two.
Cause Schilling had
already beat 11 you know,
he dropped him and hit him
with a knee on the way down.
A devastating fight for 11 but Schilling
and 11 oh they're like fucking right
there man.
I mean eleven's a piece we asked to
fight leaven in the fucking finals.
I mean that's insane for fucking rounds
with Simon [inaudible] Bruce kickboxing.
It's same,
Huh?
Three times in the night is insane.
So someone could easily die
from like something like that.
He's got to stop that and we
were talking about this the time.
Yes,
he's doing that now.
This guy Vinny sharp.
Everyone isn't getting hypnotized.
What's going on baby?
I'll call smear about code.
You have,
you have heard like Randy couture talk
about the importance of having a sports
psychologist.
Maybe that's just a nice way of saying
like maybe Randy couture was hypnotized
because when he came out then
he seemed like he had zero fear.
Randy couture came.
I'll never showed an ounce of fear.
My tie thing came out,
never showed an ounce of fear.
He came from the ghetto.
Granite Catuit came from
white people neighborhoods.
You know what I mean?
People,
you know what I mean?
So are you came out with zero theater but
Randy couture had that captain America
added.
They made Mike Tyson had that attitude
like I'm gonna fucking Rachel.
Andy said the reason he wasn't
nervous cause he accepted losing.
He was like,
I don't care.
They make different
white people in Oregon.
Man.
They make different white people.
Doris,
Eddie,
what's wrong?
What's it doing wrong
here to go clockwise,
deepest,
right arm.
How do you like to do this?
Just so many different
ways to close this off.
How do you like to do a hook?
That top leg with your right leg,
the top leg did left leg,
hip champion neckties love the Japanese.
The Japanese necktie to me
seems stronger than some guys.
Very,
very hard to choke out.
They have like large,
uh,
carotid arteries or whatever it is.
Maybe more muscle around and some guys
are just hard at Chubb and then you can
be,
have a guy in a dark,
I've had guys in dark has full blown
[inaudible] are so burnt I couldn't
squeeze.
I know I'm not going
to be able to tap them.
I'm just holding him there thinking
about my next move and I'm just sitting
there going,
I had zero energy to squeeze this dude.
I can't do it.
I got to graft or like
an arm bar or a calf.
Craig,
oh Louis get teen.
Oh Mountain.
That is the shit when you get a mountain,
when you get gutsy and
then rolls into a mountain.
Gives him that feeling of getting
that gets heat on in the mountain.
It's just so,
it's like now bitch,
so substantial.
I got Lavard Johnson's,
he palsy for PDS.
I've got him in a Doris
and Doris is my shit.
I had it.
I had it locked up and I was,
I was like,
oh,
this one's over and he's going laughing,
laughing as it's on and
punching me in the face.
Just so much fucking muscle just did not.
It did not.
No.
He pissed hot for that fight.
Oh,
we ain't got cut right after that.
Who's this guy?
Lavard Johnson.
Lavard Johnson is not
the most skillful guy,
but let me tell you something.
He hits as hard as any human being I've
ever seen hit someone in the heavyweight
division.
He hits so fucking hard
when he at Pat Barry,
I was like,
Jesus fucking Christ and Pat Barry.
That was the first guy.
What check Congo was the first guy
to Cayo with him owed Pat Barry.
But the Lavar Johnson fight was a little
more shocking to me because I was like,
man,
I thought that Barry would
be able to out technique.
This dude.
I thought there would be a lot of that
heavy right leg kick that he throws and
you know,
Pat Barry was,
you know like a Shane del Rosario fight.
He had good success against
really high level kickboxers.
So I was like,
this is going to be a hard on,
but lavar hitch,
so fucking hard upper cut dude.
He's got some life changing,
punching power,
not even close.
He's got that life changing,
punching power.
Just fucking such a meathead.
What's that?
Who's such a me?
The lavar who has bars especially
which car when his due,
he said you're going to get a hypnotist.
I might have to man maybe.
Right,
right.
How come more people who are on the shit,
my tiny going is telling you he's the
only guy in the history of fighting who
went out there scared the living
bejesus bejesus out of his opponents.
No fighter in history had a lineup of
opponents that were visibly terrified in
the rink.
Terrified.
All of them I think does Drusen right now.
They're not terrified on fire.
I don't think there's going
to be walked out to Trevor.
Perfect time or know what you walk
out too with the Katy Perry Song.
This rate board is a
good fucking growler man.
This is impressive shit.
Ray Borg is a beast.
He's going one sub to the next sub.
Yeah,
he's a beast,
man.
He's a fucking beast.
And he's like,
he's back in aggressively
and he doesn't get tired.
Well,
the guy,
he's with men,
the guys fighting ca ladies,
he's the toughest shit man is that
guys was with stid and assault.
I'm impressed.
That mean.
Look that odds right now we know.
That's why it's a thousand plus a thousand
minus that and use what's going there
and it's supposed to be a one round.
There
isn't a mighty mouse fight like a minus
a thousand and sometimes he doesn't
finish cars,
right?
Yeah,
but he's also,
I mean,
how,
what is he a one 20 fiber did.
Yeah.
But he knocked out Benevidez one punch
you don't lose is the craziest punchers
that fucking Linacre kid.
I really wished he could make one 25 they
said he can't fight at one 25 anymore
and he has to fight it.
So we're talking about technique now.
He's going for the deep half.
Look at this rate for cal
strong rate boys grappling.
It is.
Look how strong,
physically strong,
just totally dominant position.
Every position in those transitionary
periods where it Mike tipped the other way
wrong bitch,
I'm on you.
Plant you down.
He's strong man.
His grappling,
his super,
super tight.
It's tight man.
He's kind of like dropping
a shit on your head.
Free one standing half guard
hit the Camorra and dope
the head with the left leg
on his back.
She knows that's where
he lives right there.
When you transitioned that you kind
of get a free Shin to the face too,
right?
It's like the only time we
are allowed to drive my shit.
Dude.
Adam guys,
a good Kamora grip.
If it's solid,
it takes a long time to master
just holding onto that grip.
It's not really about
the Camorra these days.
It's more about just getting the
grip to get better positions.
You can get the back from there.
It's hard.
A couple of guys,
but oh tags he did.
Oh,
he got,
oh fuck.
He Yanked,
I should've quick.
As soon as the left arm was free,
he popped it right behind his back.
Yeah,
very nice.
It could be.
I'm not saying the cooler is not possible.
Obvious as possible,
but it's Ah,
generally now it's an art in itself.
You can put a whole DDB out on jumping
on a Cora grip in every position and how
do improve your position?
How to sweep,
how to get that back on.
I turned it into arm bar,
how to do this,
how to turn it into a leg lock.
Boom.
She was to come on.
It's a whole style on itself.
That could be,
it could be it's own style.
Really.
Just Bam,
xe that there's that free Shin Mean Shit.
He get drunk.
My shit phase so hard to get
that arm out at that point.
Yup.
Here he gets it right here.
Hey,
how close was a Havi to catching
Gary Tonin in the camera?
Uh,
I don't remember that.
He had him in a corner very,
very briefly in the opening
moments of the fight.
He a attack with the
Camorra and Gary told him,
wound up getting out of it.
But like you guys are speculating.
I was watching the tub watching
little stream in the tub.
Um,
they were,
you guys were speculating whether or not,
um,
uh,
Havi would uh,
go after something quick
and like right away he,
you know,
they,
they tied up or right away hot hobby
tried to lock up Komora I don't remember
that I remember it.
So he caught him,
see it.
Gary,
John and caught him with
a triangle is beautiful.
Very telling him is on five beautiful.
The triangles,
just beautiful the way
he took it from the side.
How long,
how much time did you catch it?
It took about 10 minutes,
maybe less.
No,
maybe less than 10 minutes.
And it didn't,
it was a really,
really high paced batch
hobby could easily,
he was telling me that
he was going to take,
uh,
Gary Tone.
And then into deep waters cause hobbies
known for his cardio and that's like his
style.
He likes to wear her out.
It's like,
you know,
he trains with Henna and here on the
lot that I like to wear a dudes out.
Yep.
And that's what he was telling
me that he was going to do,
but he didn't do that at all.
He went after him ruin after
Gary Tonin but it's so hard.
It's so hard to tap out Gary toner.
That's tough.
Tough.
You know what I was really impressed with?
I mean I was really impressed
with Gary Torrin's triangle,
but hobbies,
defense is insane.
Yeah.
He defended all,
Gary told his leg locks.
That's what Gary's known for.
Gary's on for known
for leg locks to do it.
He said,
I just try with lister and he
says he didn't get near my feet.
It was a real good there.
Yeah.
He or he already had
amazing leg lock defense.
He trained with Erik Paul send down
at CSW like hobby was very hard,
a leg lock.
I was going to be a
hard thing to do and he,
he spent a lot of extra time with leg
locked defense because that's Gary's go to
stuff.
But he got kind of a triangle.
Gary.
Tony got all kinds of games.
He's got everything.
That triangle is so beautiful to,
to set it up on a guy like
Havi from your side like that,
lock it in and then just go
through like every step of the way.
It's like hobby couldn't stop it.
No,
he's just,
he just,
he won his match.
Gary.
Title one is matching Polaris.
He beat Marcy and he leg locked him.
Uh,
before that Metamorris against uh,
Zach Maxwell.
You leg locked him and then before that,
the other metamorris he
did against Kit Dale.
Guillotine him.
He's not just leg locks.
His leg locks are vicious.
Does he do and Nogi or just g?
No,
he doesn't do as well.
And the gay because uh,
he's just not a points guy.
It's a whole different game.
There's a points style and then
there's a submission only style.
Two different completely like the way
you were trained for those tournaments.
It's totally different.
There's no,
no one gives a shit about the points.
Only ones.
They don't care if it's points only
and it doesn't go to a submission.
It just feels like it
feels kind of fucked up.
But when you're watching these
fights like these fights,
integration nationals,
the Gracie nationals,
dude,
those were fucking exciting and shit
cause you knew someone's getting tapped.
Then Abi,
there's the best tournament ever made
to these kind of tournaments goes on
submission only.
All that stuff.
Gary told him Ubi three March 22nd Sunday,
March 22nd at the Orpheum theater.
It's going to be on butoh videos.com
it's going to be the first one that we do
on purpose is a different one
than it is a whole new book.
There's the Orpheum was where
they film American idol.
We got hooked up.
We got what time is it times ago.
We start with doors open at two
and we're going to start at four.
It's on a Sunday.
I've got marked the comedy
and Magic Club at seven well,
I miss everything.
I miss the main show till 11 at night.
No,
you'll get your kitchen good.
You could catch it.
You might not get to the end,
but it's not going to be
at a 16 man tournament.
Can take an hour and a half or it
could take two hours and a half.
It's,
it's
like a Badass documentary.
Even if you don't know
the first eight matches,
the preliminary is by the
time you get to the finals,
you're going to know those finalists very,
very well,
so when you go see a 60 man tournament,
each match one at a time,
it really is like a documentary.
It's like UFC too.
Remember that Shit.
You got to see it all unfold where
you don't really get to see that much.
Where do you get to see that?
Where do you get to see a tournament
unfold like that and Laurie glory.
That crazy fuckers.
Glory.
Yes,
exactly.
Good.
Was that last insane?
Insane.
That's the only other place I
think they should stop that.
I really do.
I'm a big Fan of glory.
Glory to be successful.
You just use different tones.
You can do
100% that's very different.
I mean for glory.
But for a straight kickboxing is,
what do you think about that Ben?
You're active fighter.
What do you think about like
pull up that microphone man.
What do you think about the
idea of fighting like that?
Like a Gloria event?
Like it's Kinda dangerous,
right?
Three times in a night.
I mean it's definitely dangerous,
but it's also,
if you're doing it,
you're doing it as like,
that's the,
that's the goal is it's so crazy how
many people are really willing to
participate in this and really go try
to become the champion of that night.
I mean that's what got me in the fight
and when I saw the UFC back in the day,
it was tournament's.
Yeah.
Tournament's all in one night.
It was nuts.
There's so much circumstance
and I guess there could be luck.
You know,
you can win with a head kick,
Butt break your foot.
Right now you're going along,
you know,
either of trying to
fight through it or you,
you have to bow out.
And that's like Steve Genom.
Remember when Steve Genom one
cause Hawaii's couldn't go on.
Steve Gentleman,
no one really remembers him.
Those new changes versus like the
pride tournament's when it's like
this month they're going to fight,
then we'll have the next thing,
but to have it all in one night.
That's the thing,
man.
If you're going to do it.
I love the pride style.
I think we know price point.
I think we know too much about like
getting damaged and then cooling off and
then going back and getting more damaged.
We know what that's like.
The ramifications are like multiplied,
like you're getting all these concussions
and then you're going to go and have
another fight.
How much are those boys
getting paid over and glory?
That's a good question.
Does anyone know what they did?
A great,
great zero idea.
I wouldn't want to speculate,
but they're walking by a calm,
but my take is this could work
because they're on Viacom.
They're on fucking spike TV and spike
TV's making Friday night just combat
sports night.
Bella tour one time,
kickboxing at a time to
do in golden glory boxing.
It's going to be great,
but if people just pay attention,
Gloria is going to be huge.
It's just one of those,
it can't mess.
They just have to do like what the UFC
did is the UFC put the ultimate fighter
together and they spent $44 million in
losses before the ultimate fighter became
a hit.
So it was like they were
real close to getting out.
Gloria's got to do the same thing.
If glory can out how,
just
hang in there,
that fucking thing could take off.
It's exciting.
It's shit man.
Yeah.
I mean everybody wants to
see stand up fighting people.
If everybody fought the way Gary tonin
fights or the way Marcella Garcia fights,
people would love to see Nogi Jujitsu too.
Just like people love to see boxing too,
but you want to talk about
like pure excitement,
like kickboxing is
right up there with MMA.
I mean it's like high level kickboxer
with the best guys are going at it.
It's some wild shit goes down that fucking
Raymond Daniels Dude with those wild
three 60 in the air spin kicks
like a fucking video game.
He talks dude's out with
like video game shit.
He threw a jumping sidekick.
Eddie touched the guy in the chest and
then spun with a spinning back kick to
his face in the air.
It was insane.
It was some fucking literally
some video cam shit.
Well he was a bad ass point fighter.
He was a bad ass points.
Herati fighter.
I Dunno,
it was taekwondo or karate.
I mean whatever it is,
the lines are getting
blurry with all those.
They're getting real.
The techniques are going to real close.
It's going to be a tough fight,
which Zingano.
It's going to be,
it's going to be Rhonda
stuff is challenged,
but I think she'll pass the test.
What if you just rip
right through her again?
She's just like,
everybody is a new challenge for Ronda
and then she just fucks him all up,
right?
I mean it's probably,
well,
it's going to be a crazy fight.
I believe I'm here to say that I believe
Rhonda gets hypnotized before she
fights.
I'm just saying.
What'd you clarify those she might,
she gets,
she comes eyes.
Look at the way she comes up and you know,
uh,
um,
what's his name is Benson Henderson
road hair catch wrestling.
Judo.
Gene Labelle.
He's old school.
He [inaudible] he probably knows
on a complete new customer model.
They probably hit me.
I'll keep it nice and lessons together.
They got the blue belts together.
It hypnotism.
Yes.
That's the new claimant.
Ronda comes out,
she looks like she's on fucking fuck.
She comes out
with Rhonda so much better
than all these girls.
She could go on a three week binge,
no sleep.
Do all the coachee wants and
walk in and just destroy these.
You want to do whatever
the hell she wants to do.
Name,
address.
Don't throw under the bus.
Well,
I'm not saying she is.
I'm saying she could.
He wasn't saying that in all right.
Anyway.
You know what you mean?
You know what man,
it's really about Cyborg.
Drop it down to one 35 unless we mean we
don't know man and gone or you look at
that combination she
finished me should take with,
she's fucking ferocious slow has got
more competition that all those girls
combined.
So like when she walks up
with that stare like she's,
she's been down that pole.
She's been walking in that aisle
for fucking years and are striking.
It's getting good now.
You gotta worry about that shit now.
Right.
And touch them.
She bought there.
She's not the girl every thought she
grounded poner out and then they go,
oh no,
what was the need?
Oh No,
it was the thrill bullshit.
She hit her and knocked her out and then
need her so quickly and then through
her before anybody knew she was out.
She landed that before she does that.
The code.
Who Was it?
Sarah McMahon that she fucked up with
the meat before that mean Jessamine.
Duke was telling me weeks before
she's killing what the knee she's,
she like dropped jasmine
Duke with the knee,
like in training to jasmine
said she's got crazy needs.
Ron has gotten and I whoa
girls,
the girls that,
her friends,
their roommates and she said she
really wasn't training with them.
Should beat him up so bad.
The coach was like,
no,
we need,
we need dudes up in there.
We need some fucking dude's.
You imagine though that
the uncommon woman,
the pressure of that kind
of training all the three,
come on.
That's why she's just as an ultra winner.
You know it's going to take another ultra
winter but marina then she tried with
her still or no shit.
Your guess is as good as mine.
You know it'd be bad ass if Ron has said,
you know what,
I don't give a fuck about the steroids.
Let that bitch just,
steroids are still fine.
Her steroids or not,
I'm still going to know
or want to say that man.
You don't want to say that,
hey,
you need to loss and Gina Carano fight.
Yeah,
yeah.
Crazy.
Would it be,
and she said she came out and said that
that would be the most gangster thing
that CyBorD gene kratos elevator shit.
They was just like,
dear God,
someone fighters in the UFC are
doing like you have an opponent,
you know the guys roid into the guilty,
but you don't say like,
you know what?
You don't bring that out,
can't you just like you accept it.
You're like,
of course he is.
Look at the guy we're going to fight.
You don't even bring up the steroids.
A couple of people like Chad Mendez
brought it up or someone brought it up.
A couple of guys do.
But you generally,
you know that there's a good,
there's a good chance that your opponent,
it's probably on some shit,
right?
Yeah,
but this is a guy can do.
It would be like if you've
got to weigh in from Rogan,
no,
Yo homeboy homeboy was on
the soft course of course.
For the line and your mind,
you're assuming that he probably is.
Let me prepare for several
who's probably roided right?
Yeah,
but there's a big difference.
She's someone who's probably roided and
someone like Cyborg who's a girl taking
male hormones.
That's a different argument is that
she positive tested pas did steroid.
She'd be huge.
Let's have the debate right now.
He's in a while.
You know she looks a lot different now
you're looking at Cyborg now she looks a
lot like,
and that's the answer
you give someone else.
If you do,
you go dude,
if I did roids that'd be huge.
Right?
You're not denying it or anything
or just you know the real argument.
You are huge though.
Come on,
look at me.
Look at me dude.
Look at me.
Think about that.
Thanks for the compliment.
The real argument with a chick like heard
though is that how long was she doing
at four and did she
permanently alter her physique?
You know what I'm saying?
Like when you're introducing,
if you look at like you
ever those women answer
and all that good.
Yeah.
Well those women,
they used to be like Miss Olympia has,
I know one of those ladies and
she just looks different now.
Like she juiced up guaranteed
and she just looks different now.
She's in her fifties now and it's like,
man,
like what do you mean?
She looks like she thinks
it's pretty obvious.
She did some fucking male hormones.
What's she doing?
She was Miss Olympia bodybuilding,
bodybuilding or one of those Mr
Olympia or Miss Universe or whatever.
She wasn't shy.
You those speeds with the big thighs and
you think they do rides with the big,
I would think that a lot of
professional athletes to steroids.
A lot of damage.
Do you think that since the Lance
Armstrong situation happened,
do you think cyclists are
still doing all that shale?
Yeah.
There's nothing changed.
No.
He got busted.
Nothing part of the game.
What happened with that?
The next,
the next guy that didn't piss hot would
have been like the 22nd 15 it was 1515
to 16 place.
Can you imagine if your 15 mass guy that
didn't piss dirty ever was the 15th guy
in Toppenish?
They all his high.
When you guys think in a certain year,
one through 14 cause no,
no,
no.
He's saying if there's 20 guys that raced,
15 of them pissed hot,
the top 15 tests in what year?
I mean what is that?
Almost every time they always pissed off
they was giving us and they just keep
going.
It's essentially a minority sport.
No,
they do,
but see it to,
for the longest time people were lying.
They didn't have a sophisticated methods
of determining whether they're on
certain things and there was
doctors that were involved.
There's a lot of scandalous
shit that's going down.
You had on the podcast,
Kevin lead with it being a teen standing,
getting the guys fighting.
He's a beast,
man.
That fucking Zara's.
He's very fucking strong.
Yeah,
but this guy's a Jujitsu guy on top.
That's,
I'm telling you he can.
That's a deep guilt to this dude is
getting lost that tell you it's dues.
Getting through that.
It's a different animal.
Michelle Perez I think possess rather.
Oh Lisa piece,
dude.
I'm telling you.
[inaudible] grappling going,
oh dude,
he's,
he's a beast.
This guys physically strong.
He doesn't finish off in,
in the octagon.
He's having a hard time
catching guys and stuff.
But it's positioning is,
this is where you use the grease,
right?
If someone's got your back,
you're getting the tribes
physical strengths and patrols.
Ridiculous.
Okay.
But you know what?
Sometimes it takes guys like Damien Maia,
you know,
sometimes it takes guys a
few fights to get settled in.
I looked like he just
kissed him on the cheek.
Damien Maia is uh,
is gonna fight.
I'm Ryan the flair.
The main event.
Yeah.
That's an interesting fight,
man.
People don't know how good the flares.
Good.
Killaby yeah.
Yeah.
Same card man who was supposed
to be on the main of that,
Uriah Faber and,
oh,
that's right.
Uh,
Sun's out.
The Sun's how fucked his foot up.
He broke his ankle.
So now it's your,
I favor Uriah faber
versus fucking Frankie Edgar
crazy Philippines,
Philippines main event
for the Philippines.
Is that a 45?
Yup.
So gnarly,
gnarly fight your,
I'd like to ride favor 45 because
he could have all that energy,
you know,
I mean,
he,
he cuts to get to one 35.
I think it's really rough on them.
And I think even especially
as you get older,
it might benefit him to fight one 45
because he's still gonna cut a little,
you know like they're
very similar in size,
but it might be the
first fight everywhere.
Frankie Edgar's the bigger guy.
I think every UFC fighter could
learn something from your I favor.
No one's capitalize as far as business
wise opportunity then you're at favor.
These tree though,
he makes it comes to business
house real estate that he owns.
The companies that he starts
Torquey sold a k Swiss.
He's just always,
he's always,
he always has his hand in the pot
as far as just make two torque.
Makes good shit.
They're the best gloves I've ever used.
Man.
You have two velcros inside of
them that it zips up really tight.
It's a super comfortable glove.
Like I have a pair of twins that I
was using and they feel like shit now
compared to the torque torques sweet man.
But I love the twins.
Twins are nice.
They're good.
I mean I use them constantly.
I liked him,
but these torques are so good.
Everything they make is good.
Their shit and insteps are great.
Their gloves are like,
they're like the most comfortable
gloves I've ever put on.
You know what makes really good gloves?
Too high a Bussa Hi Bruce.
Dan Makes,
yeah,
that's those,
those tie pads and we have Justin holds
a tie pads for me and I had all these
older ones and they fuck his arms up.
But the high boost says man is absorbs
every old widow like those tie gloves.
When you hit myth,
what do you mean?
Do you wear like winning or any of the,
I word this for punching.
I wear the fucking torques man.
I don't wear anything but I
have like 80 different gloves.
I always pick those torques up.
Have you tried those winning gloves?
Yeah,
I've tried those.
Those are good.
Yeah.
I mean there's a lot of good stuff.
You know,
a lot of people title makes good gloves.
A lot of people make good gloves,
but I've really,
the torque is like,
it's very pliable to like,
it moves good in your hand,
you feel like you get a good grip.
For me.
It's all about risk support.
Me and my wrists are jacked.
I sold those Everlast.
Do you take the shit out of him
when you work out like a mother?
Fuck.
Do you do exercises?
Exercises to strengthen it?
How dare
curls.
Risk curls are big man.
Don't do anything with a weak link.
Don't address that shit.
Yeah Dude.
I had a bad wrist for like I had
a bad lit risk for like 10 years.
I fucked up my wrist once and it
never literally never got better.
I never got an Mri and never found out
what was wrong with it would click like
no matter what I did,
it would click and it would be in pain
every time I worked out flight 10 years.
That's me.
But you know what?
I got prolotherapy I got that prolotherapy
shit where they inject the like they
stick glucose into your vape,
your tenants?
No,
it's different things like
one of them you do for joints,
like where the tendons are
loose and you have ish dude,
it fixed it.
Like you'd never hear about
something getting fixed.
Like when someone has a
chronic something for 10 years,
it's always like,
wow,
dude,
that's some shit you got to deal with,
but no by risk got fixed.
They injected all these these fucking
needles into it hurt like a fuck.
I'm actually the rest.
It feels like fire fire.
It's amazing.
It's sore and then it sore
as fuck and they're like,
yeah,
no Ibuprofen.
Don't we want the swelling?
Just sit with her for a long tomotherapy.
Yeah.
What it does is it makes your
tendons physically thicker.
Like it can make it as much as 40%
thicker that the someone knew someone.
I want to say,
I want to say it,
Scotty from on the Mat,
one of his buddies was getting prolo
on his elbows and his knees just to
strengthen them from Jiu Jitsu does.
It wasn't even,
didn't even have an issues was
getting it just injected in.
It's a great idea.
It literally strengthens your tenants.
It hurt so bad,
but allegedly,
I mean I wanna I want to
make sure that this is,
you should Google it
before you go out and do.
It was years ago and he
was like a purple belt.
The John Jocks,
he tweaked his knee in Jujitsu really,
really bad.
And you immediately call the people
from pro though from John jocks and they
said,
come on,
come on over now.
And uh,
you had your NFX.
Yeah,
and I remember he couldn't drive,
so I had a driver's NSX and I've never
driven a high power sports car before.
So I was kind of like
grinding the gears here,
here that he was so mad.
He was fucked up and he was
killing,
he was already keyed.
Imagine he's in the worst mood.
He can be in his knee.
Just pop.
I'm rushing them to prolotherapy doc
so that we can avoid surgery perhaps.
Right.
And he's so mad at me.
I'll never forget,
you can't fucking drive with shit,
dude.
You're fucking killing my gears.
What the fuck are you doing?
He and he was panicking.
I'm like
the pressure slowly.
It's a hard car to drive,
dude.
You have to practice
six chef cars to drive.
It's different man could ever drive.
It's one of the smoothest,
easiest cars.
A Mecca driving is like come on
Nolan for being in a car to drive.
It was very powerful man.
I had a stick shift,
Pinto station wagon.
I was used to that shit.
Well the one that you drove was
the best one I ever owned two cars.
It was supercharged.
I put a supercharger on that
one and the prolotherapy.
This was like 15 years ago,
man.
Back then they didn't have
the results they have now.
Right.
The scientific data.
Well,
what happened to my knee was I had a
bucket handle tear of the meniscus,
so prolotherapy wouldn't have fixed that.
I had to get some surgery done.
There was a big opening in the meniscus
where would flip over and lock it would
like to,
the meniscus was torn and like if my
knee got tweak sideways,
it would,
the,
the torn part would tuck under and
it would literally lock my leg out.
It was rough,
so they had to go in there and
scoop that shit out and fix it.
But the prolotherapy is really
good for if you have any,
like they just had to take some of it out.
They'd take some of it out,
but they fixed it.
I mean,
it gets sore occasionally now,
but I can do everything with it
then has never needed any surgery.
He's never been hurt.
Right.
You've never needed any kind of surgery,
right?
No blown out.
Knees.
No.
Nothing.
That's amazing.
And how old are,
you know you're 31 right?
Randy coture when his whole
career with no surgery.
That's amazing.
Wow.
Amazing.
So this fucking Dude Michelle [inaudible],
he's a beast,
man.
This is a good scrap.
And this Kevin Leakin.
He's fucking good man.
I've seen him.
I've commented on several of his fights.
A really young kid.
He's about to switch on them right here.
Look at this.
Yeah.
So close.
Damn Nick Sundays,
big foot and Frank Mir.
Yeah.
Next Sunday.
Where's that at?
It's in Brazil.
It's one of the first main events
ever where one guy's own foreign.
The others.
Oh and three in his last three.
Yeah.
They crucial fight for both of them.
Well,
it's a weird fight,
you know,
it's a good fight.
Really?
Yeah.
Frank Mir fan.
Well,
I've always been a frank
Mir fan of that guy,
Frank Mir.
He can't do TRT anymore though.
That's one thing we have joint TRT.
Why not?
They will not them.
Nobody does TRT anymore.
Big Foot can't do TRT anymore either.
Fighters now,
are they stopping at
with the pee Dee is now,
I mean,
are they stopping?
Are they really stopping or are
they trying to be more careful?
Come on.
What do you think?
Can they really stop?
Can you really train that hard?
It's been consistent with the pop.
Then they'll just fuck guys
are just figure ways around it.
You gotta wonder.
It's part.
It's part of professional sports.
It's not a UFC prompts
professional sports problem.
Just UFC guys get cotton.
It's bigger.
It makes a bigger scene.
Nfl guys get caught all the time.
What do you think about it?
We can't talk over each and every year.
Every year.
NFL,
every year they renew.
Every year there's a year.
There's NFL players.
They get pop nonstop.
The number,
the amount.
How many a year on average?
Way more than the UFC.
Not even close and granted
there's more players.
10 15 a year are way more,
probably more,
more shirt,
but they don't even announce it or they
don't because it's just what it is.
Let it go.
Cause they don't have to,
cause the commission's announcing it,
the number one team that got banned the
most had the most players test positive.
And we don't know whether it's,
it could be for a Ad Rock,
could be for steroids.
We don't know.
They don't tell you that.
But the number one team who had the most
players to as positive was the Seattle
Seahawks who won the Superbowl.
Make sense?
So what,
why is it the baseball goes in
front of Congress and football,
basketball,
all these other sports.
It's just a fine or it's
an internal problem.
Why is it,
wait a minute,
didn't the Patriots win the Superbowl?
My bad.
Yeah.
Last
to get cloud.
Don't even know my bat last year.
And I love football game.
You know what I'm saying?
No football fanatic one.
The more I got into the UFC that more,
I stopped watching football and I barely
watch football every now and then I,
I,
I keep track of it.
I don't give a fuck about
the patriots or the Seahawks,
but I watched the Superbowl and holy shit,
it was getting hosting.
Craziest game.
Yeah,
the end.
And that catch the craziest catch football
history right there at the very end.
It just bounces off.
The dude's Pauline's still
give you a football man.
I wouldn't think that.
No,
the Superbowl was crazy.
And then they threw an interception
right after that and then the games over.
Oh,
how bout the Katy Perry
Rod and the lion part?
I'm not mad at that either.
I didn't get to see that.
She's a talented chick man.
I don't care.
Anybody can say that.
She's pretty and she's very talented.
I'm not trying to buy
her or music or anything,
but I see that the hook and
the hook in their music.
Okay,
let me look.
It's pretty good.
I'm going to try to buy it,
but I,
I eh,
it's pretty,
it's better than fucking
according to Twitter,
she's the most famous per person on earth.
She has the most followers out of anyone.
Wow.
I can't even tell,
Ya know way more than
like a Kim Kardashian.
Come on.
I don't know more than Obama.
What do you think she has Twitter?
What do you say he went 39 the site.
It's like prices,
right?
42 42 42 what'd he say?
56 65 woo.
This bitch has 65
I'm not even going to look.
How about that
fucker?
Bullshit.
28 Kim k's at 28 step your game up,
Kim k come on.
Well one of them as talent.
Yeah,
it's true.
I mean you can't be mad at Kim k though.
Zero talent.
Just killing the game.
Mean
Game.
What game is that?
The game mode
ass son
wearing a diaper.
You have respect for her.
She's got a diaper on to respect.
I respect for her mom and the family.
Oh,
nice to that.
Fuck.
What about meat for this?
Is Bruce Jenner really
turning into a chair?
100% a hundred percent in
Joe [inaudible] on the show.
And you,
when you look at that,
right?
Like there's this template
because I mean how many times
one of those daughters,
we always do that.
Hey,
we're talking over each other again.
I know we're not
listening to the headsets,
but one of those daughters Instagrams,
they have a picture.
I love my dad so much and
he looks like her mom is,
it is real.
It's totally Bruce Jenner gun,
a car wreck and he had to tell the,
notify the police that he's taken
hormones become a female and he's doing a
thing on him.
Follow him around his
transition from male to female.
He had to tell the police
that they were like,
what's in your system?
Because it got to,
I'm trying to get a set of tits bar.
God is the owner.
If he said it that way,
Yo,
I'm trying to get my badge on.
You said it tells how to get
some store lots over here.
What's going on?
I'm feeling a little emotional.
You know how it is trying
to get a set of test.
He claims he's not gay.
How crazy is that?
I know he likes women.
He's a lesbian.
Oh,
I have a whole bit about it in my act.
I can't do it right here though.
Oh Shit.
Look,
they're standing in front of each other.
Kevin Lee's talking shit.
Bazaaris getting tired.
Oh,
he's talking swinging.
Well [inaudible] he uses
so much physical energy.
You got to remember it's
in Denver tile altitude.
Remember when Elton John Elton
John didn't fully come out?
He came out halfway first.
He said he was by shit 10 Kevin.
Kevin Channel was like too much at once.
It's like,
I want to be a woman and I'm gang.
I think he's going to tell
people he's gay and 10 years,
I think Bruce Jenner just,
he wants me to pay Kim k
and the rest of the family.
He's like,
dude,
this is ridiculous.
She started dating guys.
You're going to start
seeing him after a while.
He's going to get busted with a
guy and then that's kind of guy.
I defended that dude too,
man.
Boy was I off.
I bet it was a conspiracy theory at first,
right?
Brian cal broke the nose.
He had a friend who was painting the house
count's gonna kill me for telling the
story.
He had a friend for painting the house.
The story.
Then that's how we work.
I'll get over it.
I
was painting their house.
Don't say what he did.
Just say working there,
working there.
I got another house.
You're doing do it.
The dudes can be fucking
threw the paint onto the bus.
Painters sign like nondisclosure
agreements to work in again,
Peyton,
those kinds of houses for real.
My guy could really get sued right now.
Just stop right now.
Kelly might be late.
Knows either way.
Count that an insight sorts.
Also known as a snitch.
Too late.
It's too late.
It's already fed.
The painters fricking.
He left town.
It's gun he's got,
he doesn't have that gig anymore.
And then what happened?
So Brian Kelly,
how did he know?
Saw wigs,
all like full man sized dresses,
all sorts of stuff with his name on it.
That sounds like the most
unlikely story ever dressed
out for a drink with them as well.
What's his house?
Look at this Kevin Lee.
Man.
It's this preservice dude's getting
tired and Kevin Lee's not
Kevin Lee's all over a man.
He hit him with some fucking sick
elbows to the head of the clench too.
He's all right.
Look at him.
He's just,
do you think it'll take on a
new name that nobody's done?
That his lungs are dying.
He's just given up,
right?
Do you think the Bruce Jenner
will take on a new name?
Hell No.
Hey,
could there be a more
manly named them burrows?
No kidding.
It's like the gay name.
It's like the game is just gangster.
Bruce Bruce Lee.
Bruce Lee is not gay.
Hmm.
Bruce is not gay.
No,
he's certainly not.
Certainly everyone got all serious.
Hell no man.
Look at this.
It's going for that shit.
No,
he's going for that leg
log with the legs crossed.
Oh Shit.
Kevin Lee's trying to
form a real naked choke.
Look at this.
This is crazy.
Crushing that jaw right now.
He's got this dude's back
because Pizarros got tired.
He's going to do it.
Oh Damn,
man.
No Way.
The Brazilian one,
right?
Oh,
is that guy resilient?
Yeah.
He just ended up
fight on that note.
Did that guy is tired of muscular.
Yeah,
he's tired as fuck.
Yeah.
You would think that like if he
does transition to beat a woman,
he's won.
He's going to want to change his name.
He's not going to stick with Bruce.
What's it?
How do you,
I mean,
what do you do man?
Everyone knows you're fucking
Bruce get changed name.
Nah.
Yeah man.
Girls do that all the time.
When they become a woman,
when they were,
they used to be a man and they
get a sex change that much.
I mean,
I have no idea.
It must be kind of fun
picking on the whole new name.
You know?
It's hilarious.
Once someone has transitioned,
you're not even supposed to
say they used to be a man.
Yeah,
you're,
you're supposed to say
they were always a woman.
Like because they're a woman in their
mind and it's cruel to say that there are
one time a man,
even if they're a man,
like it's wrong to state reality,
that they had a penis.
They function as a man,
even had sex with women and had babies,
so you just have to pretend
that never happened,
dude.
I had a conversation with this woman
and she on Twitter and she actually said
that I go,
so he wasn't a man when he had sex
with a woman and got her pregnant,
he wasn't a man.
She goes,
no,
not even then,
and I'm like,
oh,
okay.
I think we're done.
Yeah,
thank you.
Yeah.
I think,
well,
this conversation's over.
This conversation just took
a left turn down la La land.
Like what is that mean?
A woman fucked a woman
and got her pregnant?
Is that what you're saying?
Well,
it's just she's a woman physically,
but in reality he was a
dude that fuck the woman.
She's just saying he felt like a woman
even though he's fucking a woman as a
man.
You know what the problem
with that kind of logic is?
If that's the case,
if you're already a woman,
you have a penis.
Keep your God damn penis.
Okay?
Keep your balls.
You heal.
Your body will work better.
You know,
like this idea that
you're already a woman.
If you are already a woman,
why are you getting the sex change
then you're not already a woman.
Okay.
You were a man on point in time.
You're not helping anybody
by twisting the reality of the
situation and you're just making it more
confusing and harder for people to accept.
I wonder what's tougher to go from
being a man to woman or woman to man.
I would say the Dick's
going to be challenged.
I want to see a woman.
It's a man.
It's like impossible because they built
dicks out of the inside of pussies.
What does that look like?
Can you pull that up?
Jen?
Can you pull it up?
They make dicks out of the
inside of pussy trying to get
in there.
I don't want to see it like think Jamie.
I think they used fake.
All right.
My Ma.
I know one of them.
Yeah.
Where's that?
Oklahoma.
Um,
I know one of 'em.
I saw this lady grew a dick on her arm.
I'm not mad at that at all.
Like,
does rabbit's ears stretch the skin out
on her arm and created a fake penis?
When,
so when she was transitioning
and becoming a man,
I take a drink of his beer.
Right.
And he's looking at you talking,
but I was like waiting
for him to look at me.
My reaction happen I took,
cause I know in his peripheral
he thought he looked at me with,
well what the fuck?
It's pretty good.
That's pretty good.
Eddie's not a beer guy though.
It all tastes the same.
Yeah,
I'm more of a right,
right.
I like to,
I couldn't tell the difference between
Miller light and Coors light or anything
like that.
Does Kevin Lee get it?
Skin grafting in his corner.
Man had some phrase lots and appears.
Okay.
Whoa.
Look at Rick James.
Well it was quiet.
He's in a lot better shape than last
time I saw him heavenly up in this bitch.
You got leather pants on Rick James does.
They might be leather.
Look at his belt buckle.
It might be,
God bless him.
He's stealing the show.
I don't know which one it is.
Millie or Vanille Kevin.
Oh,
he's in Denver,
boy.
That's why he's got such wicked cardio,
man.
He's used to that altitude up there.
Yeah.
Thank you.
If you're not used to altitude,
that shit tortures you.
You ever seen Mark Hunt verse
Ben Rothwell at altitude?
Yeah,
we're digging.
I asked Joe Silva fight and Denver,
he's like,
we're never having another
heavyweight fight in depth.
What they did though,
they had even crazier,
they had a heavyweight
fight in Mexico City.
Yeah.
Whichever pollution.
Higher altitude and Mark Hunt again.
And Marco came in like the day before.
Yeah.
You didn't even have
any altitude training.
300 candles.
Yup.
And nobody in his court,
like he just walked and he's like,
I'm here.
Yeah.
People were worried that it wasn't gonna
be able to make the two 65 said he was
like three 10 when he got
the call or some shit.
Three ten five,
10 because even five 10
just probably five nine.
Yeah.
Cardio and weight to make two 65
you don't really want to spend a whole
Kevin Lee's good man.
You put that dude's voice with
his body and then they just don't,
there's no collusion there at all.
You're like,
how is Mark Hunt sound like
an English gentleman?
Yeah,
right.
The Dick on his forum.
Hey,
there's that Dick shot.
They wanted Eddie,
you want those dig pigs?
Can you put it up on the screen?
Was that
artificial deck like a transgender deck?
They grew it on his phone,
right?
That Dick Dick you put on,
do they put it on the arm?
They put it back on his arm
to to get the blood supply.
Keep that shit fresh.
Keep it healthy.
I don't think.
Just put it back where the Gig is.
I got a lot of blood flow down there.
Gotta wait.
Gotta wait,
can you,
can you find that transgender
deck a second girl.
Don't do it.
She didn't know weird.
There's probably guys out there that like,
that's how they get off is we're
going to eat shit after this.
Man.
We can't do this.
There's only so much deeper night.
Patrick Walsh middleweights next.
There's so many fighters in the
UFC that I've never seen fight.
Now did chest dominant eat his victims?
Cox?
Lots of parts of them.
I think one,
I think eight one dick.
He had to eat a lot.
That must have been the main course there.
Dick Cavett bonem he's going
to chop them up and eat them.
Why ignore the Dick Mouse too fatty.
That must be the,
the main course.
Hey,
look at this for health reasons.
Jamie,
want to hear what he's saying?
What is he doing with fire?
He does these like numb
church choir thing.
What do you mean he doesn't know?
He chucks,
puts it on firing.
Does a whole show with it when uh,
just on his own.
When the fuck he wants.
No,
not like what he goes.
he used to though.
He used to be a huge driver and so he's
fighting this arena probably 10 times.
This is where all our fights were in
Denver before we are in the UFC and he
would come out with those flame things
walking out to the cage and just destroy
some poor kid.
Yeah.
They let him come out and like,
yeah,
Doug was like,
come out,
you can slip and light people on fire.
It was like a Vegas show up.
It was like a Vegas show
and he'd walk the lock,
the gun beat the shit out of someone was,
he's really that good at it.
Yeah,
he's dope at it.
Whoa.
Like circus performer type.
Yeah,
he's really good at,
he's so fast was always
the kid in the gym.
We were like,
damn,
this kid ever got his shit together.
He's in be a monster.
But he was always at raves and he,
he didn't believe in Jujitsu
and wrestling and then,
and you just kept knocking dudes out.
And then finally he got with [inaudible]
or bowling or the head wrestling coach
there and all.
He's been doing his wrestling
and he's a fucking nightmare now.
Nightmare man.
Wow.
Here's a funny story about thatch.
We used to,
I got Brandon thatch,
Cody diamond who find the UFC and myself.
We all work night security at a,
uh,
after hours a nightclub.
So it was,
the three of us were security guards.
I'm used to dress up like assholes.
We had like his base,
like Shitty Tuxedos.
It was the three of us.
Nothing ever happened.
Then the one time something happened,
the boss came up to us and was like,
Yo man,
there's this Russian
dude on the dance floor.
He has a gun,
big ass gun.
He's dancing with these chicks,
man,
you guys gotta go handle this.
So I was like,
the head guy would've had like
an ear piece and like an asshole.
So I got Brandon thatch and Cody Donovan.
I'm like,
Yo man,
listen,
here's the deal.
Finally we got some action.
I was like,
there's this Russian dude.
He said the biggest
rush and do down there.
I'm like,
they want us to kick this,
this dude out and he has a
gun and I'm up that just like,
what the fuck?
He's like,
Bro,
we don't get paid shit.
I'm like,
I know,
I realize that.
So listen,
here's the plan.
I said,
I'm going to walk up to
this dude and be like,
Yo man,
you gotta get Outta here.
I was like,
Cody,
Cody at the sign was big as fuck
and he's a black belt in Jujitsu.
I'm like,
you're going to grab him.
This is,
if he puts up a fucking
kind of fight like Cody,
you're going to grab him.
Satch who's just a nasty ass kickboxer
like you ain't kicked him the head and
we're going to take him out,
man.
You know,
we didn't know the rules.
We didn't know nothing.
We're nervous as fuck.
Everyone's so nervous.
I'm sweating.
I'm like,
fuck this job.
This is my last day,
man.
So I'm like,
all right.
We even like said a prayer.
No one's really religious,
but we already kind of said a prayer.
Oh my God.
Go up
and left that part.
I know,
right?
[inaudible]
makes it way better sweating.
I go up to the dude so nervous,
I'm all,
hey my man,
you ain't my man.
I'm gonna have to ask you to leave.
We see the gun on you and
Cody's behind like knuckle,
like grip and the guy goes vomit.
I go,
Bro,
you're going to have to leave me.
And we saw the gun and you know,
we don't want to issues.
He goes,
no problem.
Okay cool man.
I like,
everyone's like ready to go.
He's like,
no problem.
Just walks out.
That's it.
I wish I had a cooler story for you.
But he was like cool and just bounce.
We probably worked another week there
that would lend even more terrifying
because that sounds like a
real goddamn professional.
He's not give a fuck.
Yeah.
I mean he's probably a dude has been
shooting people since the eighth grade and
he's like,
oh yeah,
I know I got to leave now.
I don't want to go to jail again.
Big Dude.
I got a job later tonight actually.
I'm gonna need this gun so
I'm just going to go fuck man,
that's actually quick cause I talked
to all the guys in to work in there,
but we would get out at like
four or five in the morning.
So we thought we could work
at night train during the day,
but we'd be up to,
we want to get home like 5:00 AM we'd
practiced to be at like 10:00 AM go there.
And just get dismantled.
It's Austin and especially the
glory days when we had Rashad Evans,
Nate,
Mark Cart,
Shane Carwyn,
uh,
Keith Jardeen,
all those monsters.
All of them are George Saint Pierre.
Everyone was at our camp.
You can't have five hours sleep and show
up for that five hours doing some shady
drugs and shit and not good man
fighting Russians making $4 an hour.
Russian dudes with guns.
Genuine Kelly.
Look Satish to me.
Why is he from,
okay,
Texas.
Can I do the Joey voice
with an Irish accent?
Is that possible?
I'd have to work on that.
I wouldn't want to disrespect to art.
Yeah,
that's a tough one.
Sure.
I didn't realize so funny.
Joey Diaz is,
man,
you've always told me
we had him on our show.
Oh Dude,
fucking no,
there's nobody like him.
No one,
right?
Yeah.
How old is Joey?
We were talking about the fights.
I have no idea.
Four time Olympian
and won wrestling.
This guy,
Kelly,
Daniel Kelly,
pseudo Olympian for time for time.
Judy Olympian.
He's got to be around long time.
Nobody can hear you.
You're not.
This is not a microphone on you,
so when you're talking
it becomes an issue.
Sorry.
I mean,
you've got to step up to it.
You gotta be able to
generate four time Olympian.
Damn.
That girl's hot.
Sue Burns,
right?
She's Australian.
She's that chick that was in,
uh,
the wolf of Wall Street.
She's so bad.
Dubin hot.
Stupid.
It's frustrating to Rachel.
Shit's gone down her and will Smith.
Kapow America.
The blackening has begun.
This is a cat woman.
Yeah.
Well you got the joker in this.
I might watch it.
Is this a new,
is this a TV show?
What is this Gotham son?
Gotham's most sinister.
I don't know.
I don't know about it.
Well,
as long as you don't know about it
now
I've been seeing
commercials for Gotham fall,
like a prequel or recall.
I'm a prequel.
I'll give any Batman thing a shot.
You big foot versus mirror Barboza
versus Johnson and still fight on that
fucking card.
That's a wicked fun fight with Michael
Johnson has been out for a bit,
right?
You get injured.
Yeah.
He got injured,
right?
You got injured.
Any law?
He lost his last one,
correct?
I don't know.
Pretty sure any got injured.
Yeah.
I know he was on a roll.
And the last one,
yeah.
I think you might've Lost
Rashad got hurt again.
You see that?
Yeah.
They said it didn't accept the
ACL or something like that.
I don't know why.
You know why that happens?
I would like to talk to
a surgeon about what,
what is the issue with Acl,
with a lot of UFC fighters in particular,
the graphs below or they don't work well.
A lot of times they use a,
uh,
some parts from a cadaver,
right?
Yeah.
Well that's the ones that don't exist.
Sometimes the body rejects it.
I don't think they know.
I think it depends on the body.
Correct.
So just like some people
were able to take some,
it does it just like,
just like Dominick Cruz.
Right.
But there's also people that like,
they're,
they don't give it enough time and they
were already training and they blow it
out again.
That does happen.
Of course.
You now,
I think Ed Herman did that.
I think other guys have done that too.
You know,
you don't know when they
say your body rejected it?
Are you sure?
I mean,
I don't know exactly what's going on
because what happens when you do a,
um,
a cadaver is
that it's like a scaffolding and
so it's not that cadaver graft.
It actually becomes your ACL.
It's like that ACL allows your body to
proliferate new tissue into it until it
becomes solid again.
But you don't really take the tissue.
It's like it doesn't stay forever.
You know what I'm saying?
Like this,
the cadaver graft apparently
as it's been explained to me,
it just acts as a place for your own
tissue to grow livery system for your
tissue to sort of like a little
bridge so the tendons will grow again.
Yeah.
Well you,
you sort of,
you use,
it grows in that graft.
Yeah.
How long ago did he have the surgery?
I don't know.
I mean Dominick Cruz,
I think he did it like in like nine
months after the first surgery.
He blew it out and then now he,
he blew it out when he blew it out.
He got surgery was rehabbing,
was training,
blew it out again,
and then he had to go
through a whole new surgery.
So you know,
that's why he was out
for almost three years.
Then he just blew out his right knee.
It wasn't pushed up to your face.
What are they saying?
It wasn't properly like the new
one is a totally new injury.
It's a new [inaudible] all of that.
But the other one in triple like that,
like the psychic injury that's there that
he's going to be nervous every shot he
takes every time there's a court
like that can fuck a dude up.
Yeah,
it could,
but he bounced back better
than ever last five year later.
Yeah.
It's like dudes are moving
at light speed getting,
you know what I mean?
The evolution of the sport is so fast,
so he fucked [inaudible] up though.
Man Destroys his style,
his footwork,
man,
and you need those needs to be that
quick and change the directions.
Tell you what though,
the last cruise though,
he's a beast as far as being
an analyst on UFC tonight.
He says he is a man.
He's really,
really good at though.
He's got the glasses now to let's,
he did.
He's really very studious.
Very studious.
Are they both from the
show or just this guy?
They said both.
Oh boy.
Kelly's stone cold 37 she's trying to
do this one was one 85 and one 37 years.
37 wow.
I say,
fuck it.
Let's do this.
You've got to be around a
lab a fourth time in Olympia.
Yeah.
You're not going to be a young chicken.
They said,
well,
he's 37 37 and 29
that's a beautiful beard.
Tom Johnson,
who she can do the hog again.
Ooh,
Gosh.
A raise the roof.
Did she talk to other October?
You should check this out.
Get some new shit for not like those
reps is just stick with the same old one.
I switched.
You know she's going to try it and she's
going to watch the tapes later and see
which one was best.
She,
I think she didn't get clowned for raised
the roof that is on the west coast.
Shit.
Dana's going to talk to him for that.
That'd be bad.
Feet back dancing like
stepped in my office.
You're fucking fired
for raise the road bore.
Sorry.
Is going to text her tonight.
Launch Kelly,
look at him.
He's laughing at him.
Oh,
he hit him with a right hand there,
dude.
He had him with a little
short right hook there.
That right hand is low son.
He's well he's,
he's catching him with that
weird right hook over the top.
He's caught him like three times at that.
Look at that.
Like my boy Kelly's trying
to get ahold of them.
Cows eating some meat.
Leather man.
He's getting fucked up this time.
Give off.
He's laughing at him.
Dude.
That's got to fuck with
your head a little bit.
Yeah.
It didn't feel like that dude.
Red is knocked a lot of
dudes in the bar out.
He's got a weird right hook man.
You very confident.
Yup.
Thank you.
Oh Dude.
Hammers Kelly Kelly's like real
tentative with his shooting blue though.
It was throwing the punches.
He's halfway getting there.
This guy's just target practice keeping
the same distance to he pops back a half
a step and stays there.
It gets hit.
Bam.
Right there.
[inaudible] on that front leg a lot,
dude.
Kelly's getting little Kelly
might be what you call stiff Joe.
Jesus.
Louisa's is he stiff?
It looks like the game plan
is the standard name though,
right?
You see the Melbourne
man who fight last night.
Dot.
Oh my gosh.
Ameco right.
Showed Minko or some shit like that.
That's spinning.
Oh yeah.
Oh my God.
My forearm,
those nasty,
nobody has been knocked out more than
the last two years then Melvin Manhoef.
It's insane.
I sue Lonnie just got
knocked out by Joe Shields.
You Joe Schilling put him a
[inaudible] just a couple months ago.
Those two guys,
they brought a beautiful fight though,
man.
That them coming.
Yeah.
It was one at one of them was
going to go in that round like,
yeah,
he came back too soon and then guys
aren't doing any kind of health care for
their brains to come back and,
and increase their,
uh,
the recovery time or their speed
or their timing or anything.
Ben,
didn't you fight look at this?
Yeah.
You fought for Bella tour,
right?
Yeah,
I was with them,
uh,
for almost three years.
Do you see that Kelly Caught Walsh?
What's the biggest difference between
them in the UFC as far as like production
wise?
Is it a big difference
or no production put up?
I'm not saying get on the mic.
You know what I'm saying?
Like,
uh,
like you fly in UFC,
it's like fucking clockwork.
Bert Bert has it down to a site you
flying in on Tuesday signing posters.
You've got interviews Wednesday,
Thursday,
Wayne's Friday show,
Saturday tours like that.
I think they were a little rocky.
Um,
really,
ah,
on some of that,
uh,
because the tournament's were happening
so fast that I don't even think,
you know,
they had planned out what they were
going to do as far as where's the venue,
where's the next local wow.
Where's the net?
Like,
you know,
that that's obviously a process and uh,
I think sometimes it
was like just making it,
you know,
yeah.
Just making it happen.
But they've stepped their game up,
you know,
killing cats,
man.
I was always watching when
you fuck no,
thank you.
Yeah,
It's going to be interesting to see what
happens at Beltone with all that via
car money.
Cokers no joke either man.
He also,
he does something right.
You know,
and he's,
he's way better than
anybody else out there.
I saw it was fate or at assigning.
Yeah.
Shit.
Is he the Dana White of Bella [inaudible]?
Yeah,
he's the same position.
Yeah.
He used to work for the UFC and they had
a no compete and then when he left the
UFC,
the,
he's free to do whatever
the fuck you want.
So then he signed the belt door.
Yeah.
Well it's,
it's good for everybody
because the UFC likes him.
He's a good dude.
Fighters like,
um,
you know,
it'll be way more comfortable environment
over there and maybe they'll get some
good fights and I like,
I think it's good.
I think competition is very
important for the athletes.
I think it's the most important thing
when it comes to bargaining power.
So all it's going to do is force
everybody to step their game up.
And ultimately I believe it
will make MMA more popular.
And that's the key.
The key is Megan and more popular,
making it to the point where everybody
makes a lot of money and it's really
close to,
to becoming that.
And the way it's going to become that
is if there's a bunch of fucking players
and everybody's like,
you know,
I'll give you x for a well,
I'll give you y and z.
Come here.
We got z sign right here.
Damn,
you're lucky bitch.
And I like,
it's,
that's how it's got to be.
That's the only way the money
gets tossed around adequately.
You know?
It's like we need competition.
It's the only way the
talent pool gets bigger too,
isn't it?
Yep.
You have a lot of different varieties.
Guys can come up here,
they can come up there.
Or if you only have this one place where
a guy's got to come up on the tough
show and then he's got,
or whatever your favorite
covering the NFL with one team,
Ross takes with each other.
Yeah.
Bar.
They're like saying,
come to our team and
we'll give you this much,
this much money.
So Yup.
In all ways of evolution,
it's gotta be like that.
Yeah.
It is.
It's just how it is,
man.
It's just how it is with with everything,
You need competition.
It's good.
It makes everybody better.
That's the thing.
The problem with compensation,
people get scared of the competition.
What the competition is,
the best God damn thing
that could happen to him.
It really,
I mean it's the,
it's the fundamental thing.
It doesn't mean anybody's mad at you.
It doesn't mean any of that.
It means everybody's going
to get better together.
Like you felt that you don't have any,
not only that,
you don't cancel each
other out and didn't get,
get into this because you're a fan
of fighting in the first place.
What is someone making
money somehow or another,
you're not making money.
Is that really what's going on?
Cause I don't think it is.
You're talking about someone's making
money and you're making money from a
fighter standpoint and
competition's great.
Dana.
Why?
I don't think it makes
everybody more money.
I really believe so.
I believe everybody,
it gets more money if the
sport gets more popular.
I think if you've got
two giant promotions,
have you got one?
Say Floyd Mayweather promotion at one
Manny Pacquiao promotion and everybody on
one side what the,
you bring them together and you make
fucking 1.5 million pay per view buys like
those guys will probably do.
I mean that's how everybody
gets money given up.
But think about that.
That's like each one is 50
right?
How often do pay per views in the UFC hit?
Seven 50 they don't that often.
If it's not George Saint Pierre,
if it's not Brock Lesnar,
you know it's hard to
get those big numbers,
you know,
because times are hard.
People don't want to pony up that kind
of money on a regular basis who are
watching this fight for free.
But he loves,
see Alex torn UFC.
That's it.
Everything else is like their,
their feet are organizations which
UFC top three he left sees ever.
Brock Lesnar,
Brock Lesnar number that
brought us was number one.
Never had a Brock Lesnar.
He fucked US healed again.
Really?
Ww,
it's silver.
GSP can top GSP what show is it?
[inaudible]
hungry.
How about when he fought Randy coture
for the title that had to be frank mayor.
The second is gonna be the biggest one.
I 100
yeah,
rocks.
The biggest star.
Was he coming back?
Is he what's going is
all switched to talk,
but I don't know.
You know,
there's all sorts of talk,
but I,
you know,
I had heard a lot of talk,
Bronto papers because we
can't talk over each other.
People will listen and there's no
way this is going to work with,
we were listening on headphones this,
it'd be way better,
but I want to avoid their headphones.
We just gotta be careful of that shit.
I think you guys are all doing great.
What were you saying
about Gina Carano though?
Oh,
Gina Carano was supposed to come back.
I mean that was the talk.
I kept hearing it.
I heard it from like agents.
I heard like there was negotiations.
I heard a lot of shit and
then nothing happened.
So you don't know.
I don't think the Brock Lesnar
thing has gotten that far,
but all I'm hearing is roamers
everybody's tight lipped.
But you know,
you're hearing people saying
that Brock has been training,
that he's losing weight,
he's slimming down.
I took some heat,
I took some heat people.
If I called Brock Lesnar out and I did it,
not even close.
What happened to you?
A text with that?
Uh,
this is what happened.
Sick.
This is old to six months ago,
I did an interview with the UFC.
It was 20 questions.
One was like a,
what do you prefer?
Ketchup or mustard?
We're this will kind of bullshit.
We're talking about 20 questions,
ketchup or mustard.
I said,
anyone who says mustard is part of Isis.
Like every American's gonna choose
fucking catch up and you're like joking
around.
Then question number 15 goes,
uh,
who drives see come back,
GSP or Brock Lesnar?
I said,
Oh,
well GSPS my boy.
I'd love if just became back.
But being a heavyweight,
I'd love if Brock lesbian came back.
He's the biggest star we've ever had.
And they'd go,
oh,
would you like to find them?
And I went,
well,
yeah,
he's the biggest star ever.
That'd be great if he came back.
Yeah,
I'd fight them.
That's it.
Six months later.
What about you saying about sending
them go back to playing grab ass?
It's just me like making a joke.
I go,
yeah,
if he wants to come to the UFC and he's
tired of playing grab ass in the WWE
getting paid to fake fight and
what's come back and you see,
I'd love to fight him.
Hear it too instead of like
seeing it written for sure.
It looks horrible.
Bullshit.
When they write it out,
I'm like,
that's the,
that's my friend.
That's not what they meant,
man.
That was six months ago.
You'll see the night like
whatever,
four or five weeks ago goes Brendan
Schaub calls out Brock Lesnar.
First of all,
he's retired.
I never called him out.
They just need the content.
So then the Brock Lesnar
train is crazy man.
His fans came after me like
fucking crazy hurt my feelings.
I put a statement out,
I was like,
Yo man,
come on feelings.
Fuck Sakes.
How many misspelled tweets did you get?
Oh
Dude,
I never seen hate like
when I was shitting.
Not like Tony Hinchcliffe is a crazy pro
wrestling fan and so when he was on the
podcast mostly just to rile him up,
I was just shitting on pro wrestling,
just dump it on her and um,
go tsunami of poorly written tweets.
That came my way was like,
what is this?
I had to like get my head above water
and try to figure out what all these kids
either extra words are
letters that are in the wrong
place and ra would do with hate.
Mail is one I just was looking in one
night and he's just going through it
every,
every time the guy would
send him something,
he would just send them the
corrections of the previous thing.
Like you're getting way better.
Nice punctuation.
Like and it was just this whole
fucking list of corrections of his,
like it's scripted email.
No,
no,
like the dude just saying you
suck spelled with two main ones.
Facebook.
I had grown men coming at me.
I'm like,
Bro,
you're 50 defending the WWE.
You Look Brock Lesnar's
America shit on Brock.
Measure you shitting on a man champion.
When he would fight all the wrestlers,
they would all come out,
they would all come out and watch them.
There's a whole front line of,
they're like,
yeah,
like stone cold and Goldberg
and all those guys right there.
Oh,
Brock's a monster man.
He's a beast.
He's great for this board.
Be Great.
If it came back well I
really still to this day,
oh nice left hand by Kelly.
I still to this day think that it,
Brock Lesnar did it the right way,
like a Brock Lesnar went and instead of,
you know,
doing WWE for all those years
and not striking and you know,
and then going into the UFC and
immediately fighting the best guys,
the world after one professional fight.
If they took Brock Lesnar and brought
him to like an American top team,
like one of those professional camps,
whether or black Zillions or you know,
Aka,
something like that,
when they're going to take you and they're
going to take you through every step
of the way.
Like Matt Hume would have been the guy.
I get a guy like Eric Paulson essentially
did what he could when he had them,
but I think a guy like Brock Lesnar's,
she'd been brought along slowly.
You should like,
he's got the potential to
be the heavyweight ever.
I mean,
I know he did.
He did a lot of that,
but I'm saying do it over years.
The other thing is is you know,
difficult it is to get training for
a guy of that skill set in that size.
Yeah,
that's real.
You know what I mean?
It's like you almost need to condition
them and get them tired before you would
train with a guy like that.
First of all,
huge and it's big,
but his issue is striking.
There's a lot of big guys in Holland.
You go down the hall and and
spar with Daniel Geeta all day,
you know you're going to learn
today that you can just do like,
yeah.
I'm a real believer in like if you
already spiral a lot and then great,
you know,
you're tough already.
There's no need to do that twice a week.
Right.
Go ahead and hit mits,
get a good trainer,
hit Mitts all the time.
Your fucking timing,
you be there and all that stuff.
Put that shit together.
We already know you're
not afraid to get hit.
Awesome.
You know that's the best
way to do it I think.
Well,
I think that the guys who are going to
take you like Duane Ludwig style through
drills that stimulate each individual
position that you're going to be in.
This is your response to that position.
This is how you get back.
You know,
this is your setup again.
you're like,
rob came in,
was really good about that brown bear
when he first started training with rob
came in like you saw like rob in system
and Brandon when he was fighting him.
Dwayne I think a six gun,
Gibson [inaudible] and Mike Winkeljohn,
Brandon Gibson,
man.
He's phenomenally.
See the video he did with
the elbows with cow recently.
I mean he's so innovative and he's
so thoughtful about it and all.
He's all,
he's got his love and care for those guys
and then he puts that into him and he
puts the routines together.
Man,
they're fucking fantastic.
Yeah,
there's a lot of good trainers out there,
man.
You know there's a lot of
guys out there that are,
you know,
shown guys a real high level stuff
and you see seeing like striking
combinations.
Especially like if you look at like Tj
Dillashaw versus Hanan Barao like when
one was a fucking last time we ever
saw a guy go from being TJ Dosha on the
ultimate fighter to what two and a half,
three years later being this super fluid
bad mother fucker kickboxer we can mean
you look at a moving around
shuffle and switching stances,
like popping them with straight laughs
from the fucking southpaw stance and then
hitting them with an inside
leg kick and you're like,
whoa,
this is literally not the same dude then
he was three years ago and you're going
to see more and more of that.
How much boy Duke Roufus cm punk dude,
first of all,
Duke Roufus did a great
job with Tyron Woodley.
Woodley settled down.
He didn't dim empty his gas tank
in his last fight with Kelvin,
with Calvin gasoline.
That one,
it was a good fight.
I mean,
it wasn't the worst fight in the world.
It was a good fight.
He wouldn't,
they broke his foot in the first
round and show that that's true.
Yeah.
He broke just fucking
foot in the first round.
You never knew it.
He just,
he just moved around like nothing.
But what I liked about it is he,
he showed patients in that fight,
like you've seen him in fights before
we explodes and he empties the gas tank
and the first round and then he has
a hard time in the second and third.
Like he was way more patient.
Like you could almost see Duke,
you know,
and Duke style,
like influencing him slightly.
How do you think cm punk is going to do?
I don't think,
uh,
we have any idea.
I don't think we have any idea.
I,
if I watched the guy do anything
other than throw some kicks,
which is all I've ever seen.
I saw him throw some kicks and I'm hoping
with every fiber of my being that he
was just playing around and then he
actually kicks better than that because
he's,
there's like some back stage WWE thing
where he's thrown roundhouse kicks on
like a wrestling and
I don't understand it.
I mean it's either he was playing around,
they were a good thing though.
He just started doing karate like a week
ago or you don't understand it and he's
going to mystify people.
Well or he just fucking around
because he's a Sheldon and that's,
you know,
when he's doing those things backstage,
she's not trying to show everybody
he's the ultimate bad ass.
He's being,
you know,
is there any word on
who is going to fight?
No word,
nor is there a word on a timetable
like when he's going to fight,
you know what?
They did have an opponent for him.
The Guy who fought dot Mickey work last
[inaudible]
face.
[inaudible] I've know him so well.
I could see the laugh being suppressed.
Joe Cm
punk.
No.
Um,
I mean,
this is what I think.
I don't think it's good for the sport.
Just if he goes in there and you know
he fights and people watch it cause he's
famous.
I think people will pay attention,
but it's not necessarily good for the
sport if they're just paying attention
because you see him pump.
However,
I think it is good for the sport if
he truly has a real desire to become a
professional mixed martial arts fighter.
This isn't just a money making scam.
This isn't just to publicity scam.
This isn't just a one time thing.
This is a guy who at x
age 36 or whatever it is,
is decided.
You know what,
I,
I want a new chapter of my
life and that new chapters.
I want to try my hand 100%
committed to professional fighting.
I think that's what he's doing.
I got advantage then it's good,
but
only know if he's gotten talent.
If it works.
Skill set.
Yeah.
We don't know.
We don't,
we literally don't know.
No wrestling background,
no striking back.
Doesn't even know if he
likes to compete and pause.
He does Jujitsu.
Wrestling.
Fucking pill doesn't come.
It has.
He been to the Pan ams does even know
if he likes to go through a key of eight
guys that he's going to have to go.
When I say he does Jujitsu,
he was doing Jiu Jitsu on the road cause
Henner is married to Eve Torres who was
the WWE diva champion.
So he was on the road
with eve all the time.
So cm punk and Henner would work,
you know,
once a month together
and just said
once a month,
maybe once a month
on the fucking floor you're on,
here's what page and check this choke out.
It's like fuck.
You know when you,
you show a girl something
that you're dating,
she put her you sure triangle just so
she can get her next boyfriend and a
triangle too,
just like piss on her.
You know what I mean?
They think they think
they know what you did.
You're one of the triangle
and then you don't know.
My ex boyfriend taught me Jetta.
Yeah,
I'm gonna put you in a fucking triangle
x go for a long time ago,
a triangle.
And she was so obsessed with
that were just lying in bed.
I'm trying to watch Howard stern on e
and she's trying to put in a triangle.
I'm like,
fucking God,
can you stop?
Can you stop?
And she's like,
ah.
She's laughing at me.
I'm really trying to
watch this fucking show.
And he's like,
ah,
she's trying to get me to fucking
triangle wound bed and she puts me in a
triangle.
I go,
you're going to start crying.
You are definitely going to start crying.
She's giggling.
So I fucking,
you know,
I defend like
she puts me in a triangle facet.
You are going to start crying.
So I picked her up.
I stood up just like Arona
rampage and I picked her up.
I was going to slam her on the bed.
It wasn't going to hurt her.
That's the fucking bed.
Can be good
on the bed,
slammed her on the bed.
I want to stop this right now.
She,
she like,
she let go.
She like,
oh the triangle.
But she bounced off and landed on
the floor and she like tweet Theresa.
She starts crying.
She runs to the bathroom and I'm like,
oh my God.
So I like strolling.
I said,
I told you you were going to start
crying and she hasn't hot water running.
I said,
let's go to the emergency room right now.
She goes,
come on you.
It's probably broken.
He was,
no,
it's not broken.
It's,
I would sound like,
okay.
I,
I'm just trying to,
cause I'm wondering Howard
stern traveler strategy.
Let's go cut it off.
Let's get it removed.
No,
no,
no.
It's good.
She would always exaggerate.
She was,
I told them to stop with the
fucking Tririga for a ranch
behind you.
Cause I like a domestic violence dispute.
What if that would you just fucked up?
I'm saying that's a felony.
That check's going to
come out of the woodwork.
It was 15 years ago.
I was appropriate.
What did I know?
The timeline.
Vagina.
You do not give a timeline out.
Don't say when you sue sue hoists,
I think you met 20 years inspiration.
I never hit her.
I just use triangle escape.
Wow.
That's weird.
Hm.
Well we weren't paying attention.
You didn't win.
He landed more strikes.
Did it?
Yeah.
One 2189 you know what man?
How many that make us feel better?
I would like to see.
That's true.
You're right.
But that's the move of the fight.
The move of the fight
is a half half a jab.
They move with the fight.
The fight is him getting hit.
What?
That was amazing.
That was a tricky punch.
Well,
we don't know what happened in that fight,
honestly.
We really weren't watching that fight to
watch the key moments in the beginning
where he was getting hit by right hooks.
Tate,
look,
that's,
that's part of his success
off of cats and God,
I'll use that for an argument.
Yeah,
she,
you know what?
That's your stomping grounds.
Look good.
He's
pretty good,
dude.
It's nice to find more interesting now.
One of her fights,
there's a clip of her when she wants,
she screamed and it's,
it's this fucking crime
or roar that it's like,
it's one of the craziest screams.
I remember the gentleman's mouth.
Can we find that?
I bet it.
I bet if you just Google cat Zingano,
scream,
watch.
I'll find it right here.
And she was like,
shut the fuck up.
I don't take orders from you.
That's a red bag institute.
What?
I would say that and he was like,
it wouldn't do shackle
red man by that video.
It's sick.
Wouldn't move.
He just ignore me cause I
don't who listen to Joe.
That's hilarious.
Fuck that Eddie.
Yay.
This cat Zingano smacks a drunk guy.
Cat Zingano around 10
I'm trying to scream.
Hmm.
Not motivated enough to look for it.
Oh my God.
You're the one who brought it up,
man.
I'm going to find it.
I'm not interested man.
At work.
Just talking about an instance after a
fight where she screamed at the end of
every is a fight.
Okay.
Maybe it's just like a 15 second clip.
It probably,
is it just not on youtube
as cat Zingano scream yet?
Maybe it will be now after this.
It will be after this summer.
We'll probably hear,
I'll have faith and Jamie's going
to find that motherfucking screen.
I have faith he's not.
I have been looking at
and he's on it right now.
He's,
I remember remember who it was.
Man,
it might have been a Amanda Nunez
who was her last fight blood.
Once she won,
she fucking roared.
She roars like an animal.
And I was like,
she's an animal.
It was like primal,
like a half a k Dodson.
Yes.
Girl.
Are those girls talk shit about her?
It's hilarious.
They go,
oh,
she's got a thick ways.
Oh,
she's kind of fat.
Listen.
That's what guys like.
We like girls a little bit fat.
No,
but the hips,
the waist ratio is shut the fuck.
No,
no,
you're right.
Cause she was just the third girl.
Hey Hollywood,
you a little boy.
Oh dare you.
No,
no,
no.
That's true.
Ways away.
She's very different.
Huge.
She's perfect.
But you know,
if you're gonna like
break it down for real,
like,
man,
you look that she doesn't have a like a,
like the chicks.
Have you ever or do you follow
like a squat guides on ign?
You see this fall?
Brendan's not a man.
That's cool.
Hip to ask ratio and girls.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
Just Fall Brennan Shops and Oh yeah,
you're right.
No,
no.
She's brought it up.
She's a little thick.
She's a little thing you would fucking
guts for a little Kate Hudson's son.
Yeah.
It's like a straight line.
It's not getting,
no,
she didn't have like those sexy curves.
She's boxy.
Not saying she's not say to me.
Oh yeah,
Kate Upton.
Just I'm tigall biddies though.
Tig Old biddies they're real too.
She has a boxy build on,
I don't think she's at
sexy like a sausage.
Right.
You say they are real as if
that's a good refrigerator.
What?
They're real big and they're real.
Real doesn't seem to be like the,
it's not the end thing anymore is it?
I don't feel like that's a benefit.
Like if you know what I mean?
I'm like,
they got a better way and I agree man.
I'm with you.
You like fake asses though.
That's so bad.
And I will let you know the thing that
I'm mad about it is because the fucking
legs are like little twig legs and then
you've got this huge ridiculous ass.
Get your fucking life right girl.
Do something different.
I don't know.
You see,
cause if you have,
if you're born with small titties,
there's nothing you could do
physically to grow those cities.
Get fake titties your ass just do some
squats for a couple of years and watch
what the fuck you eat.
All is showing you that you're lazy.
Girls can reshape her body.
Correct.
If she did the romance,
it's genetics.
You do ask,
watch.
You want,
if you have a flat ass like Mr. Burns,
you ain't getting a bubble.
But with the PR,
the correct squads and Tau Song,
attention to nutrition,
power lifting some shit.
I think you could do like who's to say,
I mean if this bitch went
ham on a crossfit program
is squats and nutrients shot
testosterone right into the glutes.
Well now directly,
directly.
I need some alternate that might do it.
Ask the trainers,
the stripe.
If I bring a girl with a straight
flat ass Mr. Burns style,
you can give her a bubble.
But yeah,
cause there's different body types and
now there's like active more fit girl.
Is that before and after for just butts
like flatness and curvature and all
that?
Yeah.
And I've seen some pretty crazy
before and after shots for sure.
Based on base on Yay.
Yeah,
ass and hips to waist ratio.
All that.
There's nothing so good.
I agree with what her son die.
While you're eating chips on the mic,
you are just joining this chips though.
You're destroying those.
Good,
Huh?
I those are the salt and vinegar ones.
Those are good.
I have the same ones here.
How does,
how does it feel when you,
when you first started at not doing UFC?
Is that the first shows where they
started branching out and using carelogic
watching it's better.
Right?
I like watching,
I mean I like commentary
but I'm like watch them too.
If for whatever reason I never
worked for the UFC again.
I would probably watch this as
many fights are pretty close.
I wouldn't watch the prelims as much,
like the early prelims cause I just
don't have six hours on most days to be
watching fights.
But for purposes
like how much do I enjoy it?
I fucking love watching the fights on TV.
I like the fact that I
don't have to go anywhere.
I'm home hanging out with my friends,
having a couple of beers,
watching fights.
I love it.
I mean,
I love working for the UFC,
but I love watching too.
I wouldn't mind it off.
I didn't do it again.
I'd rather do this and sit front row at
any live event as a Chinese men all day.
That's true.
How often do you actually rewatch a show?
You just occasionally a watch,
like big fights or big moments,
like something that was
like really special to me.
I just been some fights where I watched,
uh,
I watched the same fight like two,
three times in a row just to,
you know,
see like wild transitions or some shit,
depending on what the fight was like,
you know,
what was going on in the fight.
It was so interesting.
Powerful.
Neil Magni,
Neil Magni as your boy Gizelle up in
this bitch on that tough contract.
Gotta work.
That motherfucker off.
That struggle is real on that.
Tough struggles.
Real.
Tell us about it.
I mean,
I was fighting no gear for an eight
and eight when WCL got my ass whooped.
Came back on the plane with 8 million.
Wait a minute.
Eight,
eight grand in eight grade
and thousand dollars.
Yep.
Just stop and think of that.
Go to South America and
fight a world champion.
He's a world champion.
Legend.
Noguera is the fucking first guy ever.
There was a heavyweight
that had a wicked guard.
I mean Noguera is the
former pride champion.
Legendary wars.
He fucking arm barred Bob Sapp and when
the craziest fights the world has ever
known,
you're fighting him and
guess who the fuck this guy?
Super cocky too.
That idea.
Bad idea.
Then I fought cro cop for 10 and 10
after taxes on the Nogueira fight.
You're looking at it like 2,800 yeah,
no,
I basically paid for the fight.
No idea.
I was like,
thank you sir.
Here you go.
Yeah.
I fought cro cop,
I think he was 10 and 10
and then had to have after that fight
that to have reconstructive nose surgery,
Cro,
cop make that fight.
He got paid bay,
had a fanny pack on and no fucks given.
I was like,
cool you one man.
Nice a bonus check.
He got paid.
It's cro cop.
He deserves to get paid.
You know what I'm saying?
I didn't deserve that money at the time.
You know I,
I think y'all had four fights in
the UFC fight fights in the UFC.
You gotta get your nose fixed.
Reconstructive nose surgery after cro cop,
he hit me with the elbow and it shattered
my nose like completely shattered
everything in my nose.
Second round two I was like,
why in the fuck am I so tired?
I'm in great shape and I
couldn't breathe out my nose.
Blood just gushing down my throat.
How'd they fix it?
What they have to do a,
they went in,
they put like some mesh thing in it
cause all the bones were so fractured and
like tiny fractures put
some mesh thing in it.
I was trying to get a legit
nose job was like Yo doc,
take a little,
take a little off the
tip warm under the knife.
Doug,
it makes me look good.
He's like,
Nah,
that's not what I do.
Oh yeah,
you don't want them to give
you some weird fucking,
they put these brackets up there
and stitch demand so wouldn't move.
I have to chill like that for six weeks.
It was the most pain I've ever been in.
Pop and painkillers every day.
Got Addicted to them.
Take it to him.
No,
she does that.
A doctor who was like,
oh,
I'm cool.
I'm hip.
Here's 200 oxycontin.
I was like,
hell yeah.
Got The things taken out.
Next thing I know,
I'm still filling the prescription,
pop them every single day.
Do you mean notice finally a buddy had
to come to the house and take him from
me?
Whoa.
Some interventions.
Chicken a day,
probably six.
Oh my God.
This was right after I fought cro cop.
I had like 10 11 months
left because of it.
And then I fought Nogueira after that.
So you had a 10 11 month layout
because of Oxycontin addiction?
No,
because I had a nose job.
Okay,
but how long did the
Oxycontin addiction kicks in?
Uh,
I was probably,
I was probably doing it
hardcore for like four months.
Four months.
Then I,
my my best friend Joe Cloth Einstein
came over and took him from it.
What kind of stupid shit?
Where are you doing on it?
Where they had to intervene.
They just knew I was taking them nonstop.
Like what are we doing?
Wow.
They must have been.
Cause if you were just normal like this,
people wouldn't even notice.
No,
I was like this because I'm not,
uh,
I'm not,
I'm not going to delay everywhere.
Were you sleeping all day?
I think I was just out of it all the time.
Like out of it,
you know,
I'm a guy who talks a lot.
I think I was just kinda like this
fucking patio girls who just like chill.
Like I was like eventually
the beach laying around.
That's the other thing.
I was super depressed on them.
How do you take him?
I got super depressed.
How was it coming off of him?
Horrible.
How did it feel?
Super Itchy.
Has Real irritable all the time and now
you've got to fight with no gear up.
Perfect timing.
Perfect.
It must've been great.
So you fought and Idera after
you got off of the pills,
how long after?
Uh,
I,
you'd have to look at the time town.
I'm sure people can look it up.
So not,
not far after.
And then so I went off those pink colors.
Fired my striking coach.
I was so this how stupid
I was as a young fighter.
I was so sure I was
gonna knock no glare out.
I didn't even go to Brazil.
The striking coach.
I was just like,
Nah,
I don't need one but
not come out out damn.
Fuck your head up sideways.
It fucked me up.
That's a crazy thing that a doctor could
just start prescribing them like that.
Isn't it weird?
Like you don't have to go
to them to get your pill.
Like you could just take all 200 at once.
Oh yeah.
Do whatever you want and you
can do whatever you want.
I mean,
that's one of the weirdest things
about like doctors giving you pills.
I've had surgery since like on my hand.
Uh,
they gave when my neck after trash brown
fight that game seven from my neck,
I don't take them anymore.
Really?
Yeah.
I don't fill the prescription.
You just,
they take you to say
I'll deal with the pain.
Yeah.
I've got three surgeries
and I don't take him
so bad for you man.
Fuck with them.
We've
had issues with substances
in the past too.
Yeah.
But I figured it's like,
it's a trick anyway.
It just,
it just,
it,
it makes your mind pretend
you're somewhere else.
The pain still all there.
It's like a distraction and I'm like,
fuck it.
I'll freeze it out with ice or I'll take
extra Tylenol or whatever for pain and
I'll just fucking get through it.
Yeah,
for sure.
Do you still have those bills though?
Where
I went to him book my knee surgeries with,
uh,
when,
no pills,
no nothing.
Because,
uh,
when I had my ACL done the first
knee surgery and my left knee,
or they gave me,
I don't remember what it was.
It was your Vicodin or Percocet?
I don't remember.
I want up selling them at the pool hall.
But,
uh,
I took it,
I took one hit and I was so out of it.
I was like,
I'd rather have the pain.
I'd rather have the pill.
I love that.
Oh,
I don't like it at all.
I don't,
but I said I don't like it at all.
But I used to fucking love Nyquil,
the real nyquil.
Cody's daughter.
I was a little kid and just going
into a hallucinogenic state off that
awesome dude.
I took it once,
Ramy,
the last time I took it,
it was more than 10 years ago,
but I was sick.
And,
uh,
I got ahold of someone's before
they took the coding out.
And,
uh,
I just felt like shit.
I was like,
what do we got?
I got some Nyquil.
I'll take this.
I hadn't taken it since I was a kid
and I just melted into that bed.
So before,
before the rappers made
it famous ain't doing,
one's doing that little
Wayne since it felt so good.
I felt so good to that shit.
Right now.
I'm not gonna lie to you.
How's your boy,
Neil Magni you would drink some Syrah,
but you won't fuck with some oxycontin's.
Yeah,
that's right.
Do you think
Neil?
Maggie's looking good man.
He's so,
and all at this altitude is his,
uh,
cardio is going to be beast.
It's cardio is always
nasty and lives up here.
Trains up here and he's got
a style where he never like,
he's not burning out any
fast twitch muscle fibers.
He stays on you at like a 75% pace.
Always.
His biggest thing is confidence,
man.
He's getting more confident.
He's always had the skill.
It's just confidence.
The only thing that's
missing with Neil Magni,
it's like knockout power is you
know what's missing and he's just,
he's just not mean.
Neil's never,
he's not mean.
I nicknamed him the fucking Gazelle.
There's not,
I mean,
Gizelle doesn't have an
aggressive bone in his body.
He nicknamed me like Gazelle,
but he's,
he's a very competent fighter.
Like he definitely knows
how to fight huge reach.
Good Cardio.
He's a beast man.
He's just smart fighters.
Fights.
Very smart.
Yeah.
He's one of those dudes.
It's on a win streak to know
we're talking about no one talks.
So I think he's on a seven,
seven,
five,
six,
five [inaudible] seven.
Yeah,
I mean that's amazing in
this division and well,
he's on the main card,
so someone's talking about it.
Well,
he's in Boston.
He's in Denver.
Around Denver.
Yeah.
And it's a,
it's a finite Denver.
Yeah,
he lived there.
Yeah.
He lived with named
Mark Cart for every man.
I think you getting home place now,
like better guys.
What did you think
about Nate's last fight?
Is that hard to watch?
Super hard to watch.
I sent him a text and said,
hey,
I need you to come in for a podcast.
Rogan.
I'm just kidding.
No,
but for real.
So I don't think you'd be surprised.
I've learned or evolved through this.
I don't know.
You know what though?
Can you tell like,
I think it's time to go on Joe's podcast.
That's what I tell him.
No,
I wasn't doing,
unless I love them.
It's tough for me to watch,
man.
We would need a specialty.
Nate was my hero.
I missed that fight.
What happened?
He just looked bad,
like as slow is looked really fucking
good to not taking anything away from
Nate.
I think Nate's a really good fighter,
but Brad to Varas is becoming
like something special right now.
I get that.
But Nate,
Nate,
more cart ne,
a young Nate.
Nate in his prime was a fuck B's.
You're the best ever.
Really.
He's a very good fighter.
If you watch the combination that he
finished Tyron Woodley off with and strike
force when he won the title in straight.
Dude,
that's some video combat
ship spinning elbow.
Yeah,
he looked beautiful.
Look,
Nate,
it's been around a long time and a fight
since he was 17 you know who gave me
insight into Nate is you?
When you told me that he was one of his
main sparring partners was Shane Carwyn.
It was me and Shane and I.
When is the only three of
us everyday in the chill,
but just thinking someone fighting
at one 70 who spars with shake car.
I mean maybe it was one
of the five at the time,
but when Nate was fighting in [inaudible]
85 he wasn't really cutting any
weight.
No,
he walked around like one 92 yeah,
that's what he's fighting with me.
Shane,
who was walking around at two 80 me.
I was too wise to just say what number,
what was that number?
She ain't,
Shane was assault to
80 that hurts my face.
That's like the greatest training
partner to work on footwork.
But that's how I got all my,
yeah,
that's not good for your brain.
Nope.
It's really not good for your brain.
I was saying it was the
hardest he'd ever been.
He is like,
here's in a clinch and like he's got an
under hook and they're hot and he says
just this far away.
And he's like,
and fucking Bell Rung like fuck,
nobody can standard.
Dang.
He's used to stand and bang with Shane.
I'd like leave this dude.
Not good man.
Oh,
that explains a lot.
All of us are just punks.
Just stop and think about everybody.
That's Shane Carlin is sparred with
Shane Carwyn like his hands are so stupid.
Big Dead.
Literally like lunchboxes.
They'll like some fucking
Thor lunchbox shit.
Some hammer at the end of his wrist.
What does he wear at four XL?
Yeah,
glove glove.
Ever bigger gloves then
change bigger than Brock.
That's what people don't understand.
Brock's lower leg.
He lowered Kate body part isn't that big.
Like his ass.
His quads.
Yeah.
His calves aren't that big.
Shane's like a fucking Mack truck.
Yeah.
Shane is a big fucking you.
Do you know what?
I would've loved to seen what happened
with Shane if he didn't have all those
injuries from football because
football and wrestling,
both of those,
but they're back injuries to
those back into that spinal.
It's fucked up.
All that stuff is just,
that's so debilitating.
That's,
it removes so much athleticism.
So much explosion.
Like a fighter becomes so different
when they have a back neck injury.
Rowan,
Shane Fug,
frank mayor.
We're in the same camp.
Obviously.
When I forget who I was getting ready for,
maybe cro cop or no guy,
I forget,
but Shane maybe hit mits three times.
Maybe training and not much.
Man rolled him,
beat the brakes off.
Frank didn't no flux given,
well he hit the gas
from the opening round.
We got an under hook.
Yeah,
he got him tied up and he was hitting
him with left upper cuts that just looked
like he might've sparred literally
three or four times at camp.
What was perfect cause you
know that wasn't sparring.
That was an ass whooping.
I mean he just,
he grabbed a hold of them
and beat the fuck out of him.
It was,
it was a hard one to
watch because that one,
I think he took way too many
shots and not fight me or did,
I mean I think that could
have been stopped earlier.
Just Shane's short powerful punches
were just ruthless in that fight.
He seemed a little too relaxed
in the clinch against the cage.
Well Frank's coach frank,
coach goes,
relax here.
Relax here.
You're doing fine.
I'll have caught one that hell no,
you ain't doing fine.
Yes.
Shane.
Carmen,
the under hook.
That's it.
That's where he makes his living.
Everyone knows Shankar meets under like,
you better get the fuck out,
get the fuck out outside.
She even like no wrestle either.
He didn't want to wrestle ever.
What is your insight with a guy like Cain
Velasquez continually getting injured?
What do you think that's about?
Listen,
w w with the wrestling and he,
how long has he been competing for?
You know what I'm saying?
And blessing and now he's been
getting ready for forever for MMA.
Went straight into it.
I just think his body's never had a break.
Finally the body's like,
you know what man,
we can't do this anymore.
We just can't do this anymore.
You leave,
you guys like junior dos Santos to,
I mean anyone here thinks Joe Santos from
those two fights with Kane is the same
as fucking crazy.
That dude like he's just not the same
and now he just had surgery on his hand
and knee.
So junior did he just after,
after Steve Bay,
he had another surgery and he
had surgery before that fight.
So your body's telling you something
and eventually your body's just like,
we can't do.
You can't compete at this level anymore.
When you see this deep bay fight,
do you think that that was just steep,
a just getting better
and better and better?
Do you think it was junior sliding
off a little bit or do think it was a
combination of both?
Combination of both.
I think Steve Bay is that
the better I've seen Steve.
Steve Bay used to be a
training partner of mine.
I used to fly steep bay in to Denver.
He's a beast.
Steve [inaudible].
Steve Bay is a tough guy.
He looked very good in that fight too,
but I rose up a look better.
I think that really,
I thought that was the best
performance of steep based career.
I thought he rose up.
I mean I thought his,
his timing was super sharp.
His boxing look good in the
first round you do let your know.
He did take some shots but in the
first running let junior know like,
hey,
this is going to be some shit for sure.
Going through some shit,
like,
I don't know if you thought like,
oh,
I'm not fighting Cain Velasquez.
This is going to be nice.
We get a little bit of a break then.
No,
no breaks.
I'm trying to kill you.
I had a man,
it was beautiful.
I don't think juniors the same anymore.
I don't think.
I mean you can't get your ass
whooped for that for 10 rounds.
It'd be the same.
You just can't think
that's just what it is.
Yup.
I think you only have so
many rounds in your career.
It doesn't matter whether
you do it in one fight.
If you do five in one fight,
if you do one here to win this fight,
there's only a certain amount where
your body just says shuts it down.
There's a certain amount
where your body shuts it down,
but zero period and time,
which it starts declining obviously.
Like do you see it declining and
then they still fight for five,
six more years.
100% right.
Of course.
Right.
Especially with junior because
he's making serious bank.
Good shit going on right now.
Yeah.
Tr trying to get his guard pass,
but you just take,
that's,
it's just a battle of the
guard pass right here.
Okay.
Now Eddie,
when you know all the Goto Shit
from half guard that you know,
when you see dudes just kinda
hanging on in these positions,
when you see guys on the bottom,
does that frustrate you when you see
guys that don't attack or does it like,
does it like open you up to possibilities?
Like wait,
hey my students get in a situation,
you're gonna see some shit.
Like how do you,
like when you look at this
and you see like all these,
like if you look at what you
would be doing in this situation,
I would never have the balls to get
it in the cage and do any of this shit
first.
Well,
let me just,
that's very beautiful.
I've,
yeah,
but I mean when you say,
just from a technical aspect,
if you see guys on the
ground and they're there in,
in positions in the garden and
you see like sloppy guard work,
does that frustrate you or
does it make you think like,
hey,
you know,
look,
this is just great for,
you know,
my,
my fighters guys like Ben
Saunders that are trained.
Oh yeah.
They go,
oh shit and he'll magnet going off.
Yup.
He's like,
I don't like being on the bottom.
Does that fucking cardio?
Oh,
slipped,
slipped on a knee.
But still you're their
cardio Neil magnate.
Yeah.
Go,
go,
go.
If we just get a main street,
there's,
there's just so much to train when you're,
when you're fighting MMA and um,
it's a really,
really smart thing to do when you first
start getting into MMA to get your
striking together.
Cause it's the worst possible thing
that can happen is you get your fucking,
you get knocked the fuck out.
That's way worse than getting choked out.
Getting,
getting put in a rear naked
choke is kind of humiliating.
Especially if you're a striker.
It's like fuck,
but nothing's worse than getting
shut off and doing the fish.
That's the,
that's the worst nightmare.
So you have to spend so much time on
your feet to make sure that shit don't
happen because these guys are animals
that there's not that much time to really
do get the super technical
with your Jujitsu.
They're just,
there's not that much time.
So when I see,
uh,
just vanilla Jujitsu or
you want to call it from,
from fighters,
it's,
uh,
that's what I expect.
It's like they don't have the time.
I understand that they're,
they're spending most of their
time with their striking shit.
If I was,
if I had a gun to my head and something
someone said I have to do MMA,
I'd be spending my time striking
all day trying to avoid that.
The worst case scenario,
just getting shut off,
you know?
So there's just some emit
so many hours in the day.
You just can't train everything.
You know?
Neil magni beaten this.
Oh Shit.
I think you broke that left.
I think he's breaking them in now.
Tuesday,
getting 20 seconds though.
No,
I guarantee you let them get to the round.
Herb's the best in the business.
I don't know.
I think you might've been able to lie.
He might've been at the doorway
there about 15 seconds ago.
We would have been a bad call.
Cause looking at me,
no,
but I'm saying if Neil could
have landed more shots,
that's a tough sport,
man.
I never,
ever,
ever had a dream to do and a
man just not like a barbarian.
I just,
I would've done it if my back
was against the wall if I had to.
Luckily I did some things in Jujitsu
where I didn't have to fight,
but uh,
if my back was against the wall
and I had to work at a regular job,
waking up at five 30
in the morning or MMA,
I would do them in a,
but I wouldn't be happy about it.
Um,
I'm just,
I'm not that guy.
I'm not that guy like Ben and Brendan,
you guys are fucking animals,
man.
To fucking want to do it and want the
big fights and want to do it in front of
the whole world.
I'm like 99.9999% of the population.
We don't have the balls.
There's only a tiny percentage of guys.
I'm not one of those guys.
I like Jujitsu.
It's as close as I'll get and uh,
if I had a gun to my head,
I would do,
I'm in my,
but I'm not,
I'm not a barbarian.
Jitsu is fucking nerve wracking too,
man.
When I did that Metamorris I really didn't
think my nerves would get to me like
a fight,
like shop,
you're up.
I was like,
Oh shit.
Yeah,
but that's an ego thing really.
That's just pure MMA is ego and physical.
It's nonphysical hand physical,
all manifested into one.
Boom.
That's why the glory is so beautiful
when you win that glory when you,
I've never knocked anybody out in the UFC,
but I see,
I see.
And I could feel it when chuck little
Dell knock someone out and he does that.
He knows right now the whole world is
watching and he's thinking about the after
party and all that shit.
He's like,
ah man,
who's my man?
Exactly.
That's why the glory is so beautiful
because we're losing fuels the worst ever.
So most of that glory is the ultimate.
I,
everybody wants that glory,
but the risk of going the other way.
Ooh,
too risky.
So most people don't have the balls.
You guys are like,
fuck a plan.
The lottery,
like we're going to fucking do
it and you're happy about it.
He can't wait to train
Ben Saunders fucking,
she loves every aspect of fighting.
I've sat down,
had many conversations with Ben
then this is one of the coolest.
He's got his fucking hold spirituality
together and I'm so impressed with Ben as
a person and handles all this tea.
Yeah,
man.
You know he's right there.
Yeah,
it's,
it's like retired when he's not here.
Please.
Yeah,
it's crazy
shit.
Now Neil's going to be really famous.
Now Watch if you can get a
little personality on the mic.
Yeah.
Damn.
You know.
Ah,
well some lessons awful.
Neil magnates tough.
Either you got it or you don't.
There's no lesson might hire you.
I said these guys cardios
ultimate fighters,
they got to go through you.
They got to take a three week course
of Brennan shock with a big ground
workshop.
What I was asking you,
I know how you feel about
him and man you fighting.
That's not what I meant.
What I meant was like when you see all
these openings on the ground being like
her guard specialist does it like,
do you go,
oh,
does it frustrate you that
people don't know this shit?
No,
this,
there's no frustration.
Does it give you a feeling of like,
look,
this is good.
My guys know how to do shit that other
guys aren't doing an MMA and the more MMA
fighters I coach with
the right techniques,
the more we're going to
see this kind of stuff.
Man,
I,
I dunno what to say to
that shitty technique.
You're not like,
come on son.
I don't know man.
I don't know what to say about that.
What did he say about that?
And he's too high right now.
It frustrates me.
I'm not frustrated.
I understand the situation.
I understand where the,
what the mentality of a,
the whole thing.
You know,
I've,
I've been backstage and talk to so many
fighters in the UFC for so many years
and King of the case,
I've been in the business making money
for a long time backstage watching their
lives and the more I worked
backstage is the more,
to me,
I'm like,
that's too much pressure for me.
I see what these guys are going through
and all these guys go into not only the
fighters but like the apparel brands
and everyone's trying to start their own
apparel brand.
And I like I,
I remember back in 2001 rage athletic.
Yeah,
that shit.
I see these guys,
he,
they,
they put all their money because we're
going to do what MMA is getting big.
I got a clothing line and you
just see them come and go.
So after a while you see the UFC fighters
coming through and like the tough
fighters and doing it for so many years.
I'm like,
the odds that you're going to
be around in two years or so,
not good.
They're not good.
I like talking.
I'm like,
you're loving life.
I now enjoy that shit when
people weren't lasting.
Look,
you look at the UFC eight years ago,
you put on it,
you have to clean.
These fighters aren't,
it's so hard.
You know the average is a year and a half.
Exactly.
Average career in the NFLs
three and a half years when you,
if you know this right away,
it's like a scared straight program.
All of these little kids that
want to be a fucking MMA fighters,
you put them through a scared straight
and you have him sit down and fucking,
I don't want to say any names,
but I mean there's guys that
are just fucking broken from it.
You know what I mean?
You say Joe,
we're going to say ted.
I don't know.
I think that's a life that's
a string of the guy going,
I want to make my living as a
fighter and I want to be like,
I'm looking at the lights and I go,
Ooh,
I want to be George Saint
Pierre or something as
opposed to dudes that are real
mother fuckers that are going,
I just liked this.
I like to do this.
Whether there was money,
whether there's money or not.
My heart needs this expression in this
venue and I want to feel that pressure
and see who I am under that.
Like that's a whole
different kind of time.
I,
one guy
I wanted to ask you was what
do you think about all this?
A class action lawsuit
stuff that's going on.
I couldn't believe that recently.
I couldn't believe that Mac Danzig
and gave Ruediger became a part of it.
There's a new class action
lawsuit goes back me up.
What's crazy?
What is,
what is it?
What does it mean?
Like what are they doing?
I'm not understanding what a guy who's
like a gay Ruediger like what could it be
suing for?
I'm not,
I've,
I honestly,
I don't know the details
and what they're suing for.
I just know that they want the
fighters to have more of a say and,
and get paid better.
That's what the aim of class action
lawsuit and concussions and nothing.
Yeah.
So,
but what do they possibly,
what's the,
what are they saying in the cloud?
Did you know?
I don't know.
I like coming up to you several times.
Damn.
Not touching it.
Just for the record of course.
Well I feel like a very good
living messing with the UFC.
I feel like it's a bunch
of people that are like,
especially lawyers that are
getting involved in this,
they recognize that
there's blood in the water.
There was a guy that called me,
called me and goes,
do you know anybody that
wants to get involved in this?
And he's just some random
lawyer from fucking Texas.
That was like two weeks ago.
Do you think grosser and Grosser,
do you think a guy like Gabe Ruediger
or a guy like Mac Dansik who had Mac had
already,
even when I got a good career,
won the ultimate fighter and you know,
had decided he wasn't taking shots well
anymore and it brought a very eloquent
piece about it and I respect Mac a lot.
He's a very smart,
great dude.
When I see him that he's in it,
I go,
wow,
this is,
I wonder what this is.
And I wonder like,
I mean total speculation
I would have to ask,
but if some guys are like,
you know,
hey,
this is the end of my career.
I'm not fighting anymore so I don't
have to worry about pissing them off.
I don't want them to hire me again.
That's what do you think?
You can get me some money,
let's do it.
I think it's company,
he's combination is some dudes being like
the sport needs to change and it does.
Dana knows this.
Everyone in this room knows this.
Certain things have to change.
If the fighters had a union,
there's no reason we shouldn't.
There's no reason we shouldn't.
The UV under major leagues do.
Yeah.
The unions that exist in other sports,
they benefit the players for sure.
But it,
I think the,
the difference being that there's a bunch
of different teams like say if Seattle
doesn't want you anymore
and then Boston wants you,
there's like New England wants you,
you can travel around and be a part of
different teams and that's where most of
the negotiation takes place.
With the UFC.
The issue that people have
is that there's a new,
uh,
UFC,
there's no teams.
It's just like everybody's playing for
the same team because one fucking team
that team's the UFC,
it's not the NFL because the NFL comprised
is comprised of a bunch of different
businesses.
People own the Seattle Seahawks,
they own the Miami Dolphins,
they owned the Raiders,
but they're all under one branch.
You can do the NFL umbrella and
they're all under the NFL and umbrella.
And part of this union is when,
when,
so these just for then fl,
these NFL players are
destroying their bodies,
destroying the brains for
whatever the average Chris,
three and a half years.
So they're saying for those
three and a half years,
what we've given you,
we should be compensated
for down the road,
which is 100%.
Yeah,
there's,
there's without a doubt
there's some merit in that.
There's definitely some merit if,
uh,
if they were ignorant to the facts,
but now the facts had been exposed,
you know,
which is the claim about
concussions and NFL and him.
And I mean,
I think this goes with box
saying it goes to the MMA,
it goes to everything.
Once you,
once it's all out in a table and like
the medical facts and everything were in
order like you,
you've got to say,
okay,
you didn't know and they didn't know.
But now you do know.
Okay,
so now if you do know you have a certain
amount of responsibility to take care
of the people that are
under our protection.
So what does it entail to have CTE?
What are the issues that these
athletes can possibly be dealing with?
So you've got to mitigate whatever
the issues that come along with those,
those athletes being,
you know,
concussed on a regular basis.
You've got to mitigate that.
You've got to mitigate it by management.
You've got to mitigate it by counseling,
whether it's a,
you know,
having someone who's
a sports psychologist,
having someone who's a neurosurgeon
or a neuroscientist rather,
that can give them examinations,
cat scans,
all that jazz.
They should check you out on a
regular basis and that's great.
But those guys should also be compensated
down the road for risk in their life
being entertainers.
Certainly.
How about how we'll serve
peanuts for the rest of my life.
Peanuts up.
Then you start all that though.
But like what about,
what about that?
Any kid that goes into a,
into a football like you're playing,
you're playing football throughout,
uh,
throughout junior high school and high
school are those parents are subject to
child abuse then cause you're putting
your kid in a position where they're
hitting can cost study.
I think you got a good point,
man.
I think that's a real good point.
[inaudible] kids aren't dedicated
their lives to football.
They are not really.
Some of them are men.
Some of them are.
I mean there's,
there's,
there's some kids,
it's the Willy Wonka golden ticket.
Their parents realize it.
You've got a big kid
like say Brennan Shop.
I know you're happily a involved,
but what if some big Serena
Williams bitch would just
like the perfect boot?
I don't,
may I say bitch with all due respect,
of course.
It's a beautiful super athlete
is what I'm trying to say.
If someone enormous
fucking volleyball player,
like was that chick's name?
The Gabrielle Reece.
Okay.
If she wants to slang some,
some,
some eggs.
Your way fucking savages in babies.
And then you realize maybe
you're a dude who like,
you know,
you always wanted a coach.
You know you always wanted to
coach a little guy from the jump.
So you'd get this little
motherfucker [inaudible] you're like,
listen,
you little mother fucker,
you got some tailored jeans,
some savaging we're gonna make some
money and your kids like Daddy,
but I want to paint flowers.
I wish I was born a girl.
No Bitch.
Get the football.
The football are hot.
You could beat him up.
Hey Max Holloway and our boy
Cole Miller ready to go at it.
Oh Shit.
Hey Cole Miller.
Some respect.
I love that dude.
Fuck.
He's a savage.
He's,
he's a good dude.
It's fun guy to hang with.
He's always down to throw
down and maximum command.
He's a bad motherfucker.
Number goes back.
[inaudible] going to be the difference.
This can get off.
He's going to win.
Max.
Take it.
No,
I'm not fucking Cole Miller struck.
He's pretty God damn good.
He knocked out Ross
piercer with a left hook.
This is true.
That's a good client.
He's a very good by Ross
Pearson is a fucking pea.
Cole Miller Shit too on the ground.
Coal Miller's whole family
is down to struggle.
Zad still fights his dad's
Miami still shit MMA.
I sounded like
his dad is cool as fuck too.
And then his brother,
brother,
brother Mike is close.
Father.
I'll fight.
Damn coolest.
Fuck yeah.
All of them.
Cool as fuck.
They're brain trauma.
Oh they're all game is.
Fuck man.
They're ready to throw.
Yeah.
There's just like,
you don't want to fucking uh,
uh,
burglarize their house.
Your boy deals.
What do you tell him?
See Him fight more.
No,
Nick.
Well I think nick is going to
take a well deserved vacation now.
I hope they don't take
any money away from him.
I don't know what happens
with the weed thing.
I hope.
I hope it's a small fine.
He only fights once
every two years anyway.
Well it's not big deal.
I hope it's no big deal.
Cause I think it's stupid.
Unless he's fighting,
it's his third.
It's a stupid law.
Unless he's fine.
I'm,
I'm my concern always with,
uh,
with these kinds of things.
It's like what are they doing
that's helping them fight?
It could,
could there be an argument that the
smoking weed helps his Jujitsu and that it
helps us training and helps
us cardio when he trains.
Yeah.
There can be an argument.
Yesterday is,
there was a recent argument about a
ultra marathoners ultra marathoners were
there were just talk
about how they're able to,
uh,
they run ultra marathons way
easier when they get high.
Yeah.
They run in a straight line.
No,
these guys are running over hills.
They do have other still running
straight but go that way.
But it is,
fuck,
it's,
it's hard man.
It's the,
what's happening with the,
the marijuana is it reduces inflammation
and it allows you to numb the pain.
Like you're not thinking about it.
You Ain't going to fuck your
ceiling yet knocked out.
You might need,
yeah,
yeah.
No,
I don't say it's my stops performance
enhancing it is for Jujitsu.
Unless again,
unless it's bullshit,
it has been written that marijuana
actually opens lung passageways actually
opens your lungs.
What are you standing?
How fast?
But Jamie,
but that's what they're saying.
They're saying that that's what happens.
Hold on a second.
What basketball performance enhancing.
They test for it.
They don't test for it,
but you know it's almost
enhancing when people do it.
Yeah,
no it does makes it fit.
Look,
I'll tell you what it works with,
but that whole thing,
that time,
dilation,
real concentration,
all that stuff about being into the zone.
There's a lot of studies that you
guys can't talk over each other.
There's this book called the rise of
Superman that they went into all these
studies about the zone,
about being in that flow and about time
dilation and we'd like cannabis does
that for people.
It gets you into that state quicker.
Where do you become a
heightened more alert animal?
Yeah,
it can for some people,
like Nick Diaz loves it,
so I bet if you let nick Diaz smoke weed,
he probably fight better on weight,
you know,
and it helps your cardio,
man.
It just does.
Like people don't want to admit that,
but marathon waters
report that the report,
it makes it easier for
them to go hard longer.
Okay.
All right.
Let's say it does all this shit.
Either way.
Anderson Silva was on some anabolic,
right?
That's illegal.
We know for a fact that helps for that.
Now there's no argument there.
There's no argument there.
The real question is,
is it helping nick during his training?
Like is it a performance enhancer?
Does it allow him to train
and a better way in some,
but you know what?
Guess what though?
Dude,
so does a lot of shit that people do.
So does this Goddamn
cryotherapy that we do,
they're cryotherapy
allows people to recover.
So does creotine oil.
It's like there's a lot
of shit that bothers me.
Make wheat elite.
How bad caffeine,
caffeine,
Halo loud.
I got a question for you,
Ben,
as well.
If they decided to just legalize steroids,
everyone,
steroids,
would we see fighters,
uh,
jumping up in weight or
staying right on the father?
Act like fucking Alster Overeem
is serious cells in 12 right now.
Seriously fucking legal.
You would
probably get bigger.
You'd want to get bigger?
Uh,
I don't know.
What other,
what'd you get bigger?
If it was legal,
would you use it?
I don't know.
They said we're going to legalize it
because he could go away at that point I'd
say show me the money.
Okay.
If I've got to go up,
they get the money and it's legal.
Exactly.
So most people would just stay the same,
right?
Yeah.
But you're talking to heavyweight.
I would look like then step up on
that micro quince for you though,
it wouldn't really be effective
to add more muscle mass.
You're optimized physically for frame
at one seven eight do you agree?
I would say so.
So if you were going to go to one 85
like a few like say you want to do it,
but if you wanted to do it,
if you looked at it like super
objectively with no desperation at all,
they're like,
what's the most,
what's the most intelligent
way to plan that out?
How long do you think you would take to
put on that kind of mass and keep and be
comfortable to go to heavyweight?
Yeah.
No,
no.
One 85.
He's like,
if you're going to go to one 85 and
you really decided I'm going to be a
middleweight fighter now I'm going to
abandon this idea of cutting weight and
staying lean and restricting my
calories and dehydrated myself.
How big would you want to get?
Ah,
I mean I'd roughly just tried to do
the same thing I'm doing for one 70.
Just obviously we're dealing
with 15 pounds heavier,
so,
but what would you do,
do,
would you give yourself a year?
Like two,
like if someone,
uh,
how much time can I start?
I my first four fights where,
what w one 81 85.
But I was stepping on
the scale with my jeans,
right?
Like lower level.
I mean,
like four fights you're saying if I
was in the UFC and items like that,
I mean,
honestly,
I don't know the science behind my body
type and how long it would take me to
produce that much,
uh,
additional muscles.
But it's something that you
would have to really consider,
right?
Yeah.
Like if I was going up to one 85
I don't know if I was going up,
but you wouldn't even do it.
No,
no,
no.
The same.
Right.
Well,
the reason why I was asking was one
reason is because Henderson's tonight just
fought at one 55 like a month ago,
and now he's stepping in here tonight
and he's fighting fache who is a giant
fucking welterweight,
walked around that.
He'll be,
he'll be one 90 in the cage.
He's a big boy.
[inaudible] he's long lean
and he's super aggressive.
Great strikers.
No,
one 70 that's what he was when he
was cutting a 55 but since then,
I bet he probably can't.
It's only a month ago.
I bet against gain five pounds.
So maybe he's like,
well,
who knows,
man,
maybe it would be better at one
70 where he's not dehydrated them.
So maybe you'd be like a rumble Johnson
types of Jewish don't don't you think
like steroids and p Dee's benefit really
wanting 85 and above because those
bladder guys really then
maybe they're using EPO,
who knows,
but they're really not going to use the
antibiotics cause they can't put on them
maybe more prevalent at
the higher weight class.
It would help for
recovery during training,
but they got to cut weight for a little
bit for recovery growth and a little
test all the time to stay recovered and
do two a days all the way through and
not suffer overtraining as
much and then get clean.
You ain't going to get
in that much like that.
That Belko dude man,
he was interesting as fuck.
Yeah.
He's a fascinating guy.
And you know what man,
one of the things he's been saying over
and over again is that these testing
techniques are ineffective and
that these urine tests are given.
Fighters are just,
you know,
and everybody was calling bullshit on him.
He was saying they were just,
these are just intelligent test.
Yeah.
What's his name?
What's Bunko cat's name?
Victor contents.
But I had them on the podcast,
the interesting cat,
but after it's all over Maine now
he looks vindicated in my opinion.
I mean,
he's vindicated.
God Damn.
What were they dogging him about?
I apologize to everybody going to say
that John Fitch would never piss off.
I said,
Bj Penn and John Fitch oils guys will
ever piss hot and when John Fish Piss hot,
I found out that Santa
Claus wasn't real a really,
have you seen him in this last one is?
That's the first thing I noticed was like,
that doesn't look like regular John Fitch.
John Fitch has some big biceps with
giant water hose vein coming through.
He's getting,
he's,
I still didn't believe it.
He's huge.
Do you think it's possible that it wasn't?
That's all.
Is there,
is it possible that when guys
say that I need another test?
[inaudible]
the same shit.
Well,
Anderson Silva's train.
Have you ever seen the picture
of Anderson Silva's trainer?
Jeff [inaudible]?
He's 60 and that's like the hall
really close to him and he's a Strayer.
Guys always around that are saying,
don't do it as a good dude.
I like that guy just
ate that guy's sandwich.
We shared a lunch one time and
he got my head and I pissed.
[inaudible] gave him a
back rub with hot cocoa.
Wait,
because a pds is that it doesn't like
that that bigger muscle mass isn't going
to actually maybe dictate that you're
going to have better use of that muscle
mass.
Well the lightest guy in
the UFC and title fights,
it's pissed.
Hot has been a Allah
Allah Ya bug routine off.
He pissed off for EPO.
Come on.
Just the best one to fucking
with EPO at that weight,
that weight kick rocks.
You know what he's got?
He wanted to be able to do what he does,
which is he has like this very kinetic
style where you use a lot of muscle.
He explodes a lot and that shit gets
you God damn exhausted possibilities
fighting mighty mouse who's
sold the opposite of that.
Mighty mouse is super technical.
Every is always in the right position.
And even when he knocked
out like Joseph Benevidez,
it wasn't like some crazy windup punch,
you know the through all
his body weight into it.
Who's just super tactical that so he
could do that for a hundred rounds.
If somebody wanted to fight
mighty mouse for a hundred rounds,
you could probably fight
you for 100 rounds.
Just pulling guard pounds,
pulling guard earlier by the cage.
[inaudible]
he's a little high.
I really believe.
I believe leg locks are going to
come back in a big way in MMA.
Oh sweet.
He might have it.
You've got to let go of that one though,
right?
He's under that.
He's caught.
He's under the level.
This is the problem.
Leg locks right here.
See,
I don't think he should punch right and
I think she would defend the leg lock
can get out of the cute guys usually get
tapped out when they go to punch strike
before Bossy [inaudible] she is.
I'm not mad.
I don't give me raw.
Kicked her out of my bed.
I just want to hug her and marry her.
I would not married.
No.
Called you out?
Oh my God.
I love random.
Got To dinner and you guys went out.
Hung out.
You see what said,
I want to marry you.
How much money she's one of my girl
makes her look like Oscar the grouch.
It's the greatest
description
ever,
ever.
My girl makes her look like
Oscar the grouch with tits.
Holy Shit.
That's funny.
That's a funny Jolene would say.
That's exactly like what
some Joey would say.
She looks like Oscar the grouch with tits.
It's
probably smells like I'm too lazy,
Bitch.
See that bit dirty feet coming here.
Boxy.
You don't want to be boxy at 22 either,
by the way.
You really don't because when
you get 32 will look different.
48 hot discipline girls
that never talk about it.
Guys.
Physical attribute like a c
he's gotta get his ears were no,
somebody in Beverly Hills.
He just,
I mean you just gotta do
some about those years.
Well I heard Rihanna.
What do I know?
I'm like fucking TMZ.
I heard Rihanna broke up with Leonardo
Dicaprio cause she said that he just,
he has too much of a belly.
They were dating.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
And she,
he had too much of a balance and
asked him you to six bed for her.
Really cool.
To her.
Something like supermodel cause it,
yeah,
I'll get on that while he's
balls deep in some supermodel.
Wow.
Cool story Bro.
And then just flex them.
See,
where did you hear this story from?
Online man.
Oh Bro.
Oh Max Holloway.
This spinning back kick
Barstool Barstool Oh yeah,
I'm,
Oh yeah,
I'm all over that shit.
She's throwing them under the bus.
Said he had too much of a gut.
That's hilarious.
Yeah.
He's,
he doesn't have fucking time to work out
cause he's doing a list movie all the
Goddamn time.
We're picking up all
these officers and blow.
Yeah.
That's what Chris Brown whoop
that ass talk in that way dude.
Tait Fletcher just went there.
Did you hear that?
Did you seem him to Django?
Did you not hear what tapad is incredible.
He was incredible.
Damn.
Max Holloway just landed
a nice right hand.
You know what?
You don't see that,
you know,
you don't see that much
to them and made that uh,
Roy Mcdonald's
does so well.
Is that question mark kick
like I was just looking,
Cole Miller grazed the top
of his head with a kick.
Right.
And I was like that Kik will you come up
and it looks like a front kick and then
you turn into the Brazilian style.
Roni does it almost every fall.
He does look again.
Let's look at that.
Rory does it really well.
I think Serone and a
motherfucker out with it though.
She only so good at it,
man.
Yeah,
that's Ronnie does out pay.
Owe a lot of dudes.
You know who's good at it too.
Who?
The very first person I ever,
ever saw do it and knock the dude out.
Mark [inaudible] mark.
Nope.
That really,
really right.
If that,
you know,
uh,
pedis can do both
traditional and south Paul.
That's both like a motherfucker.
Oh No,
I got to son.
He's not going to,
he's like looking for parts
of his eye in his poem.
Damn.
Oh.
Ruins.
Oh my God.
You've seen Biz beings.
I just shot a show with Disney has that.
She has careers.
It's bleeding.
This is awful.
Oh Shit.
Is that the eyebrow that's bleeding
or the eyeball that's bleeding?
I hope it's eyebrow.
I hope.
Look at this.
Look at
Po.
Oh,
it's a heads up that's
telling me I had no big God.
Damn,
that sits a bad cut then there isn't that
a horrible spot.
They'll stop it way better
than what I imagine.
That's a big cut,
man.
It's not that big.
It's the,
I look at the top of the eyebrow.
I'm looking at the blood coming down
the corner and I was assuming that that
whole thing was kind.
I don't think that was my first referee.
The referee said they keep going,
but he's,
he said,
you got to clean my eye,
so what's it going in my eyes?
Yeah.
Did they bring somebody around
waving it off to me he was,
oh,
no,
but he's not going to clean it off.
I don't understand that.
Then what did they do?
Did they don't,
they usually cleaned it off.
If there's a headbutt
like a cut like that,
they have to look at it.
Doctor come in or someone
come in and look at it.
Yet they usually,
that's where I would think they would do.
It's only if the fighter can't
see those don't affect him,
his eyesight,
but it is right now.
It's,
it's affecting his eyes.
Said he's trying to
wipe it out of his eye,
but only if it's in the eye.
If it's going around,
I,
they don't stop it.
If it's in the eye,
then the doctor though the referee
brothers coming over to talk to him,
he gets five minutes,
right?
Five minutes.
Yeah.
So he's saying,
fuck it.
Let's go.
He goes,
sometime this fiery guys up.
This could be the change in the match.
You know what I'm saying?
Dude gets pissed.
Well Dude,
like Cole Miller,
he's been fighting angry since he
was a baby that shits in his jeans.
He's from the south.
Cole Miller can scrap these scraps.
Is that inside leg kick?
I don't know.
If only knows.
Hit Max Holloway acts and Ben
Henderson have the exact same back.
That two identical.
It's true.
No,
but isn't Benson's like angel wings and
his is like one angel and one devil is
it?
I think Max,
one of them is like a a devil wing
and one of them's an angel wing.
I'm not sure someone has that,
but one of the guys,
well,
the,
yeah,
that's right.
That right.
One's a little different.
Is it going to say,
well,
we'll see what he turns around.
Well,
there is one fighter.
Yeah,
they're both,
they're different.
Maybe they're just two
different kinds of birds,
but one dude has it where
one side looks like,
like a bat wing,
you know,
I don't know his kids right when it
looks like a battling that left one looks
like tattoos.
This is getting real gay boys.
Ooh,
nice low.
Yeah.
Huh.
You know,
like sponsors,
like alien ware.
It's going to be weird.
And then not allowed
to sponsor UFC fights.
I've used to see in that,
that alien logo for so fuck.
Yeah,
it is.
It's at one of them is like a devil way,
right?
Yeah.
Oh,
that Combo was nasty,
but it's going to be sad seeing those,
uh,
those,
those sponsors go,
those sponsors support or a lot of bison,
especially a alien ware man.
They've been around so
long supporting fighters.
I bought an Alienware computer,
even used them to sponsor
my podcast just to Sorta,
there's still bellatore
to say that you know,
like just to respect them because
you know it's like it's a big deal.
He about High Bussa
they've been around a grip.
Yup.
They have.
Yes.
They have to make some mixed.
The best ankle straps,
they covered the whole instep.
They're the bad.
They're the only brand that covers
the whole insect killer that bad.
Right now.
It's like they can't see patty or no,
am I right?
There's little,
it's kind of like padding
to tie pads or the Shit,
man.
They're the best type ads.
Like there's a real difference in like
how they feel to the guy who holds him
after I'd be done holding them with you.
I would.
My tricep should be burning up,
ma'am.
How long have you guys
been trained together?
It's a long time.
Came in twice.
Anything knows.
That's how bad it looks.
Bad,
bad place shaped like a head.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
Cool.
No,
terrible.
I think it's cold.
Oh my God.
It's huge.
I think it's a great idea,
son.
Dude did you see the cut?
It got bigger.
I think it got bigger and big caught
his final punch when he was in the guard
right before the bell was
right on the button again.
Oh really?
See that's kind of fucked up,
right?
Oh look at this.
Nope.
That's nothing right.
They're terrible highlight.
But it's not like a hat,
but it's just like he's rubbing
it like he's just going to die,
man.
Yeah.
It's unfortunate that your eyes fuck up,
but well the mind,
the amount of known it was a little
fucked up when he's grabbing his head in
there.
Let's be honest though,
for sure.
I mean he's,
he's aware his head hitting the cut.
It's pretty bad though.
It's a lot worse than I thought
it was cool to feel in drag.
Drop it in front of his eye.
Yeah.
But when a company like high Bussa like
take something like tie pads that have
existed forever and just
makes an improvement like
that where you know you could
absorb harder kicks with them.
There was a way they can
make their cushioning,
whatever it is,
he doesn't hurt nearly as hard
when someone's kicking that.
Have you ever had blood
in you on the spot?
Cause the oil,
the oil,
you can swipe it just doesn't go away.
It's like having a film of
straight motor oil in your eye.
You just can't get it off.
It sucks man.
Everything's blurry up Coles.
He's in trouble,
man.
Max Holloway is a tough kid,
And he's had some tough
fucking fights in the UFC,
but he's night.
Yeah,
he fought Conor when he,
he made a decision because kind of blew
his ankle or his ACL out and I met up
with Connor yesterday.
He was in Venice.
He's a big ass dude.
Hell yeah.
He's big.
Conor McGregor is,
I get to one 45 like a professional fuck.
He's,
he's a genius.
He's got to get by Josie Aldo.
Oh,
got some tough.
That's a tough,
a tall drink.
Josie.
All know for him though,
Conor McGregor versus me
get star Anthony Pettis.
Think about fucking Matt.
I agree.
He's not going to,
that's going to be a
different fight for Conor,
right?
Yeah.
But wait a minute.
What about Frankie Edgar?
What about trying to do,
what are you trying to do?
You want to see him loose?
No,
we need Panisse.
Needham's yes,
he's going to wrestle him and I'm like,
I'm all list.
I Love Frankie,
but I'm,
I'm team Connor after yesterday.
Man.
He's a good dude.
I'm all team Connor.
I it with the right matchup.
That kid,
he's,
I think he's our biggest star.
Um,
easily.
I love Frankie Edgar meet you.
Love Conor McGregor too.
I don't want to pick a side because
there's part of me that was so I love Cub
Swanson to WHO's cuddlers caught?
Pardon me?
That was so impressed with Frankie
after the cubs wants and fight.
I think it's a crime to not get
my title shot after to that.
I agree.
I think it's a crime.
The defense team beaten cub,
Swanson like that and beaten Dennis
Seaver at the end of his rope.
Is it just totally,
you know why it took time?
Because think about what
Frankie's gone through.
Think about Frankie's robe,
right?
But the thing is if you get Frankie
Connor Union destroy to superstar,
do that man.
Well,
you gotta
give this,
you can give it a you.
Although that is key.
The fight with Aldo.
Okay.
Whoever wins that fight,
then Connor fights that.
That's how I would do it.
I give common one more warm up.
Most of Connor fighting Aldo.
If he wins.
Okay.
Diverse.
Goddamn.
That's I like,
I like seeing Aldo,
Josie,
all the right now.
I like that as a fan.
I love it.
Exactly that UFC note,
Connor,
Josie,
all the right and the Ui and he knows that
that's the way the matchmaking Japan,
they think of a fucking
match up and they do it well.
You don't have to build up the shit.
It's like,
let's make it happen right now.
I just feel happy about it
as common as management.
I'm like,
Bro,
let's get one more it.
You're in a fight kind
of a grappler wrestler,
cause don't get it twisted.
All those a black belt,
it goes to the ground.
There's gonna be some issues
there and he can wrestle.
He's hard as fuck to take down to,
I say you give him one more match up with
kind of a grappler guy who's going to
try and take him down.
I think Conor is going to,
I think Conor is going
to hurt him standing.
I don't think it's going to go to the
ground and then he really hits that hard.
How many more minutes do we have to see?
You know?
You know why he's so confident is I
really think that everyone that he's
training with this going,
Holy Shit,
this guy,
it's so hard,
and he's like,
fucking everybody up.
That's the confidence he has.
He's proving it.
He's hurt.
He hit Dennis Cbre with a
couple shots in dentistry.
We started buckling quick.
If was system power as Joel get shy
came stiff once he thought the power.
Now he was stiff from when
he flew in on Tuesday.
Yeah.
By the way,
knocked out Dustin poray.
Nobody ever did that before and I'm
saying I'm on the top of his head.
I think he really,
he's so confident because he knows that
these guys at 45 can't take his power
animal.
He's not saying the guy's
at 55 could take his power.
I wouldn't be surprised if if
like let's say he'd be Josie,
I was on his end.
He's going to fight Anthony Pettis,
right?
It's going to be him.
I wouldn't be surprised if Connor said,
hey,
I knew for a fact that could be all those
guys at one 45 I knew there was no way
they were going to handle my power.
Anthony Pettis,
he's like me.
He's got serious power.
Crazy strikes.
Ooh,
this is like a 50 50 fight.
You know what I mean?
I this guy to overlook
this guy would be stupid.
This guy is a beast.
He's just like me.
We'll see what happens though.
Sonya says fighting pedestal,
man.
That's going to be a good one.
Yes.
Competitors just seems
fucking unstoppable,
dude.
He's so confident and you take them
down and submit you in a second.
You're taking up those Angeles
grapplings up beast man
pedes can submit anybody.
They'll submit any by Henderson.
I agree.
He,
that guy knows how to squeeze Max.
He knows how to take arms.
He's very good on the ground.
He's a finisher and the way he throws
a stretch so powerful with no wind up,
he just doesn't wind up right.
He throws some taekwondo styles.
Yeah.
There's no way with power,
they'll say everybody's going
to be a tougher fight for him.
I think though it's going
to be a tough fight,
but well,
the tough fight off Habib number good.
Madoff is the tough dude.
I'm trying to tell cowboy,
don't fight him,
man.
Wait for your fucking title shot
because at one 55 to get a top shot,
it's going to be a fucking nightmare.
Is he going to fight that guy?
Is that the the story man,
so they trying to set
that fight up for sure.
You just fought fucking
six times in a week.
Could be.
Takes the time gangster.
Yeah.
It's great to be gangster,
but a certain point in his
management needs to be like,
dude,
sit out.
You'll matter.
One
will never fade away.
Cabo will be around for as long as he can,
which is great.
Which is great.
If I'm as business business manager,
I'm saying you wait for the title shot,
you've won.
What?
Six in a row and you're getting nicer too.
You'd be one of those shady managers
that they fucking get on the underground
and say,
fuck,
Brendan's should die.
You don't want me to just,
you don't want me to manage dudes.
You don't want me.
And how many managers
stories have you heard?
I can manager after manager
aftermath with a Tz don't fight bro.
Wait,
wait man.
You've done all this work.
We're in a great opportunity.
You're going to get a title shot.
Let's wait.
Don't fight.
It might have to wait a long time though.
Habib's ahead of him in line.
You know,
there's a lot of fights out there.
I mean he might have to wait a while.
You wait.
Title shots.
Think about how hard is to
get a towel chat one people,
are they denying fights?
Vitara that happens every now and then.
But generally Dana white offers a fighter.
Joe Silva and you fucking just,
it your Donald Cerrone and you're fucking,
I mean him and Dana Command,
he could command fights or fucking,
it's like stepbrothers.
You don't,
it's like they're boys.
Yeah.
So I'm sure he can be like,
and think how much he fought for him.
He thought Ben on a fucking,
what,
two week?
Three week notice you're fucking hanging
out with and you win seven in a row.
You wouldn't second row.
Yeah,
we'll cowboy wants to fight a lot.
I think he feels more
comfortable when he fights a lot.
He gets better when he fights a lot.
I did not go with that advice.
I wouldn't know.
No for immediate title shot
if he was in live for it.
Immediate title shot,
I would say that's good advice.
Wait it out.
But he's not.
There's other guys that had of him,
this shit could take a year.
Look what a pedes hurts himself again.
Okay.
Pedes hurt himself with Gilbert.
A lot of people were saying,
but that interim fights,
no good man.
But when Pedis,
champ pedis hurt himself,
how to get to go through surgery,
he's got through at least two surgeries
and there was rumor that he hurt his
hand or something after the,
the,
uh,
the fight with Gil and it
turned out that wasn't true.
Or if it was hurt,
it was okay.
He could rest it and it'll be fine.
But anything could happen.
Look at the fucking heavyweight division.
They had to have an interim title because
at a certain point in time it's like
canes gone through another service.
I like Jesus fucking Christ.
And when you can't wait
around for a title shot,
if that's a situation cause you can go
dry as cowboy fight so much better when
he's active.
I think it's good.
It's good.
General Advice,
I think what you're saying,
but like cowboy foot so much
better in his head is locked.
Like his head is in,
in to the lot better.
I just don't want to
see if fight could be,
the thing is he,
so he takes off six months or
whatever it is and he comes back,
he's not going to get a tune up fight.
He's going to fight somebody
that's a fucking savage.
It's almost better for him
to stay in the fucking woods,
you know,
almost.
Yeah.
I just,
I,
I just think it's bad or good.
It's good to stay in act to stay.
I think,
uh,
first of all,
a guy like Norma Madoff is,
uh,
an elite grappler and it'll show
you where cowboys defenses and
where his back game is.
Cause Cowboy has a very nasty
triangle that people forget about God.
He's got a nasty game,
was badly super finished
with very nasty off his back.
So,
uh,
I wouldn't say that he couldn't beat
Namaka met off and if he did beat normally
come out off,
especially if you fucking showed
his versatility by submitting them.
I mean,
you would think if cowboy is going to win,
like most people would say
probably by knock out right?
Like normal gum it off,
hand up.
Yeah.
He'd had kicked him or something.
But man,
if he caught him with
something on the ground,
man,
that would be even more
impressive in my opinion.
Me Catch him in his own realm when
they're a Madoff is the elite grappler.
Whether he could do that or not is a big,
if you know like a guy like nick
or Madoff's 50 doing combat,
sambo combat sambo world champion and
you watch him fight dos Anjos it's pretty
obvious his grappling his on some next
level shit cause he just took that dude
to the ground.
Anytime you want it to rag Dalton
zoom or pounded on his face,
elbowed him and he'd be design
Joe Sanchez beat Donald.
Any beat Ben as well.
Like a Conor McGregor.
He's not fighting these elite grapplers.
Yeah.
So why does cowboy I
have to fight this boy.
I think he's the one that too.
I think he wants to and if he wins,
God damn dude.
If he wins,
I mean think about it.
He took the Benson fight
with two weeks notice.
A lot of people think he didn't win.
It was a very close,
controversial decision.
I thought personally I thought
Henderson was going to get the nod.
I didn't rewatch the fights.
I didn't,
I'm not committed to that.
I'm not married to that.
But I thought like,
I think Benson was more effective.
He did more shit,
got more things off and I knew cowboy was
pretty banged up going into that fight
too,
especially if the way
it was kicking miles,
juries legs when he was taboo.
I didn't look good in that.
But yeah,
he looked like a guy who
just fought two weeks ago.
You know what I mean?
You still look good,
but it took a head kicked in
and fucking played it off.
He got head kicked at
one point in time by,
by Ben and played it off well like
you could see him stiffen up though.
Like he got,
he got wrong.
It's tough man.
You fight and then you fight.
Two weeks later you're
going to be busted up.
But she couldn't,
that weight there,
there has to be some sort of point of
no return where your body's just like,
dude,
we can't keep doing this.
But then you see the show.
So you look at Nirimba Madoff and
he's been out for a long time.
He's had a knee surgery and then I
think he fucked something up again.
Like,
I think he hurt his knee and then,
and then retrained too quick
or something like that.
He's been out for a long time,
so he's trying to get back
on the men because they,
the reason why they gave
gill the title shot,
I mean,
I think Gil was supposed
to get the title shot,
but they were going to have Norma Madoff
was in the mix and they tried to offer
him a big fight,
but he couldn't take it
because his name was fucked up.
And that was like about six months ago.
I forget what fight he couldn't take,
but,
so he's been out for awhile too.
So it's not a bad time
for cowboy to catch him,
you know,
if you want it to look to you going to
catch up if you're going to catch them,
it's not a bad time.
Or they both Greg Jackson,
they both trained no
roofs.
Tom Hobby love these jobs.
A lot of those crazy Russians
and a Benson beet root.
Some hobby love.
Yeah.
So that,
that was a big win for him.
That fucking lightweight division
is filled with murderers,
man.
Just murder.
Murder.
Oh man,
so many audios.
They got a really good
shot of beating Padis.
Well,
you know,
got the best shot.
He's got a,
he's got a strong grappling game.
He's very physically strong.
He looked at Nate,
Nate Diaz fight.
His grappling game is very strong.
He's very fucking big.
He's very fit.
His leg kicks her nasty shit.
Kickboxing.
Yeah.
So it's like he's not a,
uh,
like an easy out on the feet.
It's not like,
you know,
pedis could just light
them up on the feet.
You know?
I think it's just a strong too,
I think it's to be on the feet.
It'd be interesting to
see if pedis can get off.
Pedis is definitely quicker and it's
definitely more experienced against world
class competition and being successful.
I mean,
pedis knocked out cowboy,
you know,
I mean,
pedis is,
he's something special.
He really is.
But at the South Pole,
it's going to be interesting.
It's going to be really hard for
anybody to stand with Pettis.
Yes.
He's too scary.
He doesn't get hit so hard with all this,
the unorthodox stuff.
I mean,
he has the craziest kick.
Love to see Conor Aldo do it.
Yeah.
I wanted to see,
although versus Pettis and they
were trying to set that up.
Where are you?
And let me tell you something.
Pedes was ready to go down to one 45.
He doesn't give a fuck.
He's like,
I want to fight that dude.
He goes,
I think I can beat that motherfucker.
That's when he hurt his knee.
Right?
Yeah.
Imagine pennys going to remember
they were setting that up.
They were setting up that Superfight
pet is going down to one 45 and fighting
Aldo would be fucking crazy.
Looking at those two guys
facing off against each other.
That would be insane.
The Funny Eric Silva break him down.
Eric Silva is a,
a very aggressive dude.
He's a very tough guy.
Like you look at his
fight with Matt Brown.
He,
he's a a ferocious dude for like the
first round or so round two rounds.
I've never seen him do like,
uh,
like a normal combat bed
off type fight or uh,
dos Anjos fight.
I just don't sign just the way he ground
down Nate Diaz for three rounds get
dumped.
Took her down and smashed him,
constantly work and constantly working.
Eric Silva,
I think especially earlier in his career,
it tended to run out of gas,
like John Fitch outfits to them.
John Fitch just kind of took them down
Malden and stayed on him and warm out.
He's just got worn out.
He's not the same guy
towards the end of the fight.
And Matt Brown,
that's Matt Brown,
his world,
you know,
he's,
he's in a drown in bitches.
Matt Brown drowns motherfuckers.
That's what he does,
you know,
and Eric heard him,
he heard him in the first round.
He hit him with a nasty body kick.
He's got a real good
left kick to the liver.
He throws that kick and throw it like
a front kick to throw it that way too.
He's really good with his,
his distance was kicks
is super aggressive.
His ground game,
his real solid,
but he's just,
he,
he to me it's like he's
emotional or something or it too,
too much adrenaline or something,
but it doesn't seem to hold a,
that he could sustain.
And if you get in there
with a guy like Matt Brown,
like you gotta know when
to lay off the gas man,
you got to know when to recruit.
You got to know what
kind of shape you're in.
And Matt Brown,
Look,
Matt Brown exposes people
he did to Wonderboy.
He exposed Wonderboy,
not,
I'm not saying this in a
negative way towards Wonderboy.
I think Wonderboy,
what was exposed in that fight,
according to my conversation with one
voice that he overtrained he said just he
was really trying to deal with the
cardio and the shift that Matt Brown was
thrown out on.
But he said he might overdid it
cause he was just like real flat.
And then you know,
Matt,
you can't,
you can't have an off day when
you're fighting Matt Brown rice guys.
Right?
His pace breaks.
Dude's [inaudible] Silva.
I think Matt eventually broke them.
Oh,
is this just like,
what the fuck?
He's not saying it's ferocious.
Round is going to be a beast.
He's not laying off.
Got My book,
I got my boy killed.
It'd be all day canceled.
So unusual,
you know,
and the more you concentrate on
training with this motherfucker,
you're to me or like,
like I've been waiting
for someone to come along,
I'll others outside of Aoki,
but of course I,
okay.
You always have those crazy
tights on and it's like,
it's,
it's so hard to find someone in MMA that
understands that guard correctly and to
be able to have the kind of flexibility,
dexterity you have in rap guys up,
you're going to see
you get into positions.
Like Jason Day was when he fought um,
uh,
Alan Belcher in Canada.
He wrapped him up in that mission
control and drop some bows on it,
man.
And you realize like if someone
is good at this position,
you leave someone incredibly vulnerable,
incredibly vulnerable.
It's just that position is there all day.
The position to lock up arm's mission
control in order to get to like a good
place of completely controlling a guy
in a way that you rarely see and closed
guard.
It's,
the technique is around in grappling.
I mean you see it in grappling,
but in MMA it's,
it's fairly,
and it's not because it doesn't work,
but to me it's like wheel kicks.
Like for the longest time we just didn't
see him and everybody didn't think they
work.
And then Barbosa lands that
fucking nuclear weapon on
Terry Edom and everybody's
spinning now.
Veit tours,
winning,
spinning,
heel kicks,
knocks out.
Luke Rockhold was a
fucking spinning junior.
Dos Santos hits Mark Hunt with it.
I mean it's,
I think that once someone sees what a
guy like you is capable off of his back,
it opens up so much defensive
possibilities and so much
authentic possibilities
too.
Like your way safer defensively and you're
all fence off your back in positions
that people don't think
they're vulnerable for.
You know,
like I get what he puts her fucking
hands on the mat in the UFC.
Everyone,
everyone does.
Everyone does.
You put your hands on the mat at his
school and you're going to have an elbow
problem.
Do you do your scanning of your shit
snapped or you're going to get snapped?
He was in cold Miller's corner.
Oh,
okay.
Yeah,
he's a no,
Gucci is a great thing
about Ben is that I get,
I've had so many MMA
fighters come through and,
and,
and uh,
I
try to add the rubber guard or
other techniques to their MMA game.
Um,
and sometimes some more to come and
they're striking will be really bad.
They got really good Jiu Jitsu.
They want to do MMA.
They just started striking six months ago.
They want to add rubber
guard and I'm like,
okay,
we're going to add rubber guard of a man.
Like you got along way
to go with your striking,
you know,
or a guy will come from
a wrestling background.
Really good wrestler.
Not that good striking
just started Jujitsu.
He wants to do,
I'm in May.
We got a lot to work.
Oh,
we got to work on it.
A lot of other Jujitsu than Robert go
and I'm just going to work on rubber
guard.
We've got to get your passing together.
We got to get your guard
retention together.
We got to get so much
other stuff together.
Like this is a longterm project,
but there's,
they're awesome.
They're awesome people.
Yeah,
they're awesome people.
And then sometimes you have a tremendous
striker coming to me and that I want to
learn some rubber guard.
Mike has zero wrestling and as
you Jitsu his blue belt level,
and the same with them,
you have tremendous striking.
That's awesome.
But man,
Dude's gonna try to take you down and
you've got to have garner attention
skills.
You got to have so much other pieces
of the game that it's not just rubber
guard.
So it's a lot of things
that you've got to work on.
But when Ben came to me,
he came to me with UFC experience.
He came to me as a black
belt from Ricardo laboriel.
So I don't have to really
work on anything else,
but just really,
and he's,
he got tremendously
long legs for his size.
He's six,
three,
six,
two,
three but he's got the
legs of the dude that six,
eight and they're super flexible.
He's super flex weed and,
and a lot of guys that come to me,
they're ready,
they're ready to find,
they're doing pretty good,
but they don't have the flexibility.
We got to get the flexibility again,
that could take a year,
that could take two years,
that could take three years,
that could take two months depending on
how much time they're willing to put in
to their flexibility.
So would it be,
Ben came to me already a
black belt from MacArthur.
Laborio already had his
flexibility already was playing uh,
uh,
versions of the rubber guard.
He was already bringing
his legs up on and,
and he's an amazing striker.
Jesus Christ.
It's really,
it's really easy for me.
Like he wants to stand up.
He don't even want to
take it to the ground,
but it just seems like at least his last
two opponents in the UFC wanted to take
him down.
Uh,
w what was his name?
Seth Heatherly.
Chris Heatherly.
Chris,
he wanted to take you down.
He saw your tape when
you look at the tape.
And to be honest with you,
I'm so buried,
had been buried,
which just life,
the last few years I haven't
kept up with MMA like I want to,
I just don't have the time.
And I kind of,
and I never watched Beltre
when Ben went to Bella tour,
I kind of lost track.
I saw one or two fights.
I lost track.
Jesus.
So be kick you just through what happened.
He's a hell of warm and not to just
through a wicked fucking around Casper.
So anyways,
he says in the Serena,
all this fight coming up,
all his fights were in this arena.
This is what I'll say about anything else.
It's wrap it up before we get real quick.
I just wanted to finish.
What I was saying about Ben is,
um,
he came to me and I really didn't
know how good of a striker he was.
Hit not the letter,
I'm just the one that
came up to me and said,
do you,
have you seen?
And you know,
what do you know about a strike?
I know he's pretty good.
He's got good knees,
right?
I remember like the killer knees.
He goes,
dude,
go watch him on Youtube.
This guy is fucking super killer.
So I went and I watched the highlight
reel of Ben Saunders and when you watch a
highlight reel,
like,
oh shit,
it's a highlight reel of
him fucking starching dudes
and fucking him up with all
sorts of shit.
Jimmy's head kicks,
spinning back,
fist,
elbows,
boom man.
It's,
it's uh,
it makes it easier to
teach someone when they,
they're,
they're already coming as
a killer teen killer bee.
What do you think,
what do you think Benson Henderson is
Wayne right now as he gets into the
octagon?
Like how much do you think he was cutting?
What do you think he
probably weighs right now?
One 75.
180170170 one.
Well,
so you think that that's all he weighed
before he started his cut down to one
55.
One seven one which is not
much bigger than just spot.
It's hard to put that.
He just bought a Brandon's thatches head
coach leaser bowling wrestle in college
with Ben Henderson and
they're super close.
And he,
that's what he was saying.
The advantages,
Ben walks around at may one 70,
barely.
And we know that on a strict diet lean is,
fuck,
we'll enter the octagon tonight
at one 90 which is crazy,
man.
Wow.
So it was a big difference in the size.
So you're talking about,
we're probably looking at
a 15 pound plus difference.
There's your board Joe rigs,
15 pounds.
And you're talking about a dude who,
who's a Kale artists too
at one 70 that's a shit.
Looks the,
and he doesn't look good.
Grappling is different,
but grappling will be the difference.
What I was gonna say is his,
he ever fought somebody at this level
has Benson is at a very high level.
I agree.
No,
he has it.
This is like the biggest
Paulo Thiago in Brazil.
Yeah.
But Paul,
Tiago is nowhere as good
as Benson Henderson is.
I know.
All due respect,
the highest level he's fought.
And it was in Brazil against him.
You mean supplement wise?
Yes.
I love it.
He said yes.
Just kidding.
Well I wonder how many guys,
man,
how many guys did get the fucking
free pass from the doctor,
my friend.
Don't worry about this.
I got the right your and
for you and this one,
I mean it had to have happened somewhere
along the line in some country where a
local guy got a free pass,
a drug test.
That would be a giant scandal.
If we found out that someone in the
athletic commission and some place was
involved and doping
someone like helping some,
some fucking Super Geronimo type dude,
you know,
it's crazy and we want surprise me.
Damn.
It wouldn't surprise me.
Surprise me.
There's some more surprises about Bruce
Jenner turned to a chick straight up
that surprise the shit out of it.
It was
shocking.
I go,
I want to go back to the podcast.
When were ragging on calendar
about it and listen to it.
Olympian.
It's a limb.
We'll the best Olympians.
Everest.
Is he the first cornflakes
box or something like
corn flakes?
Bruce Buffer.
More airtime.
He's doing all this cool shit right
now that you have any last UFC.
Well,
people were more into what he does now.
Like even the,
uh,
the UFC appreciates it now.
Like these wacky moves they used to
be embarrassed by his whiskey moves.
Isn't it true that Eddie Bravo gave him
the idea and the inspiration for the
buffer?
Three 60 no,
no,
no.
I was not the buffer.
The Matrix,
the matrix buffer was a different one.
He never ran with it.
It was too hard though.
The three 60 it was too hard
cause there was one way we wait.
Don't say it was too hard.
Say the fans when he phones weren't
ready for this move where instead of just
going like that are spinning
and going like that.
Like him going like this,
keeping icon coming through like that.
I like that.
I can't even do it.
You have to practice.
But the idea is like,
like that.
Oh yeah.
He didn't want to do you gotta
have some good back flexibility
right there and keep an eye contact,
keep eye contact,
anything like that.
And Joe,
Joe,
you know,
let's say,
let's say thatch knocks him out.
What to do for that because she
really fiber puts them on the map.
Put them on the map,
right?
Yeah.
Cause such a big,
big way,
but in one 70 does it,
does it make a statement?
One 70 yes,
because he did,
he talked about doing one 70 before.
Everybody knows is a big one.
55 or he's a world champion.
I mean Benson Henderson
is legit world champion,
class fighter,
UFC champion.
I mean he's stepping up to 70 for sure.
But for thatch,
that's a giant wind and for
Benson is to let everybody know,
hey,
you know,
I can fuck some people up
at one 72 including really
dangerous unheralded young
guys that no one wants to fight.
And that's that.
There's a lot of dudes that
do not want to fight that guy.
You know?
I know a couple of guys turned the fight,
that big motherfucker.
He's a beast.
He's,
yeah,
he's a thick dude.
This is going to be a hard fight.
Athletic too,
man.
Grappling.
Zoe's been is his Achilles heel and you
can tell like eastern doubt in his mind,
Ma'am leasters have been
working on with them.
I like a mother fucker mother.
At least he knows his shit,
man.
He used to no sleeping
in the wrestling room.
Least at Boeing's.
No struggle.
Yeah.
In Elliot Marshall helping him,
he would go for 54 if you want
to keep up with us a bit away.
Hello.
That's just,
that's just a superstar in Denver.
Two men.
You saw the billboards that Cami
is here to walking him down.
Cleared size difference.
I love Ben though,
man.
That's his real confident
God switching stances.
Making a mess.
Well,
Benson's got to get some
respect here for sure.
He's got a tag him with something that
gives him at least some concern because I
want,
if he shoots though thatches knees,
man,
they're legendary in Denver.
Really?
Damn you could already see is kind of,
he's just waiting for
him to shoot his knee.
His fucking nasty.
You're chewing.
I'm like,
Oh shit.
I'm sorry.
Last chip
shot by then you have that.
You weren't really loud.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
This is to be in the clench
with that either man.
Dude,
this fucking kid stand up is good.
Nice set up there.
I like it.
I think with the right to
set up distance for the left,
he's super creative.
Men.
Look at that.
Benson throws that Hook.
You got the last guy who
I saw as creative as that.
Just the Cup Swanson.
Is that right?
Yup.
That's amazing.
And you said that he's been trained by
his dad since he was a little kid since,
yeah,
since he's in diapers,
man.
That's cool.
He used to come in the gym and we,
we literally just watch them
just destroy cats with knees,
south Paul Rec,
traditional stance,
whatever you want to like how he
switches back and forth effortlessly.
Yup.
He's got that nice check.
They're two real key switches.
F Ooh,
Nice.
Right hand to the body.
But the body shot by Benson Henderson
is back and he's chasing him down.
But listen,
the longer this goes,
the better it is for Ben.
That's his biggest fun.
Oh,
big kick to the body.
This is not looking good.
And over the top bike dad,
God damn these look like they're
not looking good for Henderson,
man.
You remember to thatch,
like I said,
he's fighting this arena
eight or nine times.
He's the main event.
Pretty uncomfortable.
He's used to being,
you know,
the star attraction.
So what you're saying is
he nervous?
Has Nasty elbows.
Two minutes.
Oh damn hard.
Inside leg kick check by Henderson Dude.
He's big.
Oh,
nice.
Front kick by Henderson
and knock them down.
It doesn't hurt them but
it keeps them honest.
Get off your back
southpaw
did he hits hard.
You could see it.
It's very fluid with his kicks man.
See how he's switching traditional sound?
Both nasty.
Yeah.
Superfluid man.
Oh,
oh,
he's trying to set up a kick.
Yeah,
I'll see.
I was dropping his hands.
Stand sideways looking
for this being my friend.
If I'm Ben's coach,
I'm saying getting against
the cage and and wear him out,
man.
Give them to the third and fourth down.
He sat in some money.
He's like,
he like,
he sat in a spin up.
Yeah,
it looks keep sending up was spinning.
He keeps doing it like he keeps leading
with that laugh when he gets that left
forward.
He's looking to spin with his right side,
but he just isn't pulling the trigger
on is thinking about it too much.
That's a nice inside like her.
I like that body shop.
Benson,
his land
just so much stronger.
Damn.
That's where five minutes is a long time.
This kind of scrap.
Ooh,
nice body kick by Henderson.
That's what I'm insurgency thatch
and the third and fourth round.
Oh
sorry
dude.
He's going after Benson
going after him,
man.
Oh,
Nice Jab.
Great Name.
Big kickup.
Hi.
Right.
Ooh,
Nice.
Nice Combo by Henderson Bait and switch.
God,
he's fast it cutting them off.
And that's just from a karate background.
You said background and
his main sparring partners.
Matt Brown.
Whoa.
Not Brown.
And Neil Magni are the guys
that rotate in and on him.
Matt Brown lives on his couch
when he does his camps in Denver.
No Shit.
Yep.
Matt Brown lives in Cleveland,
right?
Yeah.
Cincinnati or Cleveland,
I think since uh,
Cullompton addy,
Columbus.
Columbus,
Ohio,
right?
Yeah,
Columbus,
Ohio.
Cause he,
I know he trains at a west side barbell.
Yeah,
exactly.
Does that shirt that loose?
Those guys are bad ass.
I got one of those reverse
hypers in the back.
Oh sweet.
Too.
Did a seminar with the power that the
people with the strongest woman in the
world and her husband and shit.
And it's fucking phenomenal.
Like it's,
it's awesome shit.
And it,
and really it's something that all
fighters like as far as like when you see
guys lose knockout power dudes that you
used to have it starch and dudes and
then they don't,
and they're just like,
it's like they're just happened
dudes now I feel like their,
their training has been misused in a way.
Why is you're saying?
Yeah,
and they,
and they actually lose
that power because it's,
it's weird.
It's like,
it's like what,
Jujitsu is the same thing.
Like were we didn't see a lot of rubber
guard for a long time and now it's like
creeping in and all that kind of stuff.
But that's like,
there's a time in Emma in MMA
where there was nobody that was,
um,
it was pushing a guard game.
They're like,
stand up and,
and scrap again.
Right.
And the,
and that's because the coaches
didn't know any better.
And now like a lot of guys like Duane
Ludwig's or the world that are like actual
fighters that came out and now
they can put that together.
But that's changing the whole face of it,
I think.
You know.
So you mean like now we've seen
that with strength and conditioning.
So what you're saying now we're seeing
that with strength and conditioning as
well.
Yeah.
Well you never forget.
It's a bunch of people that don't know.
I hooked by Benson that
Marv Marinovich camps,
those Marmar Mark Marinovich camps at Bj
went through for the best performances
of his career.
You know,
he hated doing it,
but man,
watch Bj when he fucked Diego Sanchez,
he was a mother fucker.
Yeah,
sure.
See you right.
He was doing all that USC.
Yeah.
He was doing all kinds of crazy shit.
I mean,
there's videos of him working out.
He said he was so tired at night.
He couldn't even pick up his baby.
You know,
he said it was just exhausted,
but Ooh,
Benson caught him.
But the,
the result was incredible.
Oh,
looking for it.
The result was incredible.
I mean,
Bj in that kind of tip,
tip top condition is such a motherfucker.
Did you see the roots
will fight Bj documentary?
They send that to you?
Yeah,
they did.
I haven't watched it yet though,
but I heard it's amazing.
It's awesome that way.
You want to Bj Penn shirt,
will they send it to me?
But I just watched a documentary
yesterday that yesterday back to Bj is a
difference.
Yeah.
Bj was a beast man.
There's leaster bowling,
Christian Allen,
the masterminds behind Brandon Thatch.
Oh Nice.
Now do you think that's
just starting to slow down?
Yeah,
it looks like it,
doesn't it?
Yeah.
It's interesting.
A theft in the third and fourth round man.
Well that's,
well,
how about the fifth if he gets into that,
right.
But what is the knock on him
as far as his conditioning?
He's,
he's really,
it was knocking everyone
out in the first round.
So we really don't know.
I mean,
I'm training,
he's always been obese cause
as long as this is all standup,
he can do 10 rounds as if Ben
starts grappling with them.
I think Brandon's going
to be in some trouble.
Do you think maybe a
Benson might know that?
It might be like looking to stand with
them with the first couple of rounds and
then where I'm down to third,
fourth and fifth and then start taking
them down if you had a be in his corner.
Yeah,
that's exactly what I'd say to do.
Well the thing is is like I said,
at least her bowling is really good
friends with Ben and Ben's head coach
Crouch.
They just the like uh,
when co cowboy and Ben Flat.
Oh they just toss and he told him.
He goes,
yeah,
the best Gamer camp right now is Brandon
thatch and do any told them about him.
She's like,
he's this monster and the next thing
you know they're fighting each other.
Dude,
that switch the Oh spinning back kick
to the body that's switched than he does
where it makes it a little bit,
he's going to throw a right kick and
then he sets up the left or left kick and
he says it with the right.
That's some beautiful shit,
man.
That's something you only see in like
high level kickboxing most of the time.
Good job at that man.
Ooh,
Nice Jack gotta be waiting for it.
Right?
Or maybe just things to do is too big.
It doesn't want to fuck with that.
Oh that's a high level grappler wrestler.
That's a beautiful fucking jab.
Right hand or jab left hand.
But then Ben just went for a leg.
But that might be to keep them honest.
You know,
I think Ben needs a switch.
It up can get,
I'm guessing man.
Ben is thrown a lot of right hooks.
The body.
Oh yes.
Oh it was that.
Oh he loses his balance right there.
Nah,
it looks like right.
Then I'll come back and try
to press him on the fence.
If you could hold a little rock,
but his legs being pinned against
the fence by him would be death.
Ooh,
good body shots.
I bet he goes up top soon.
Good move.
I'm moving these main event
fights to five rounds.
Right?
He might have for the fighters.
So much more entertaining
used for the players in camp.
Yeah.
Ooh,
Nice.
Straight left.
It is a great to watch,
but you got to think they
can't like steep meo chicken.
Uh,
junior dos Santos.
Like how many of those can you do?
Oh Damn.
He needs to not stay down here though.
Wow.
He just tossed back.
What happened?
I poked their something.
Something happened maybe.
Wow.
I love that show.
Respect in the middle of combat.
Those guys just hugged.
No one's even talking about it.
Oh,
beautiful.
Jab and then switches.
Stance.
Got Angles,
dude.
He's,
he's very creative man.
Very creative.
Look at that.
Rack
them up though.
Stay on their bed.
How about keep holding on that leg
and kicking the shit out of it,
dude.
Yeah.
I think if Ben's going
to try and win this,
he needs to go for singles and get them.
I liked that right hook to the buyer.
Then stepping in with that
is he's landed that a lot,
man.
That's a nasty shot.
Yeah.
That's a nasty shot,
man.
You might be trying to set up the up top,
right.
Get a guy to get used to cover covering
that because he expects it and then go
over the top.
I think that just a number head kick,
he keeps going low into the body.
Well,
he would think that he would
have an advantage in speed,
but what he might have an advantage is,
is,
is pace.
The ability to keep that
pace up for five rounds.
He's done that so many times.
Like Benson is a master at understanding
his own limitations as far as like
cardio.
Like he keeps a solid fucking pace.
He knows exactly how to red line and,
and he could read it for five rounds.
He knows his body real well in wars,
you know,
let you think of those
Frankie Edgar fight.
He's got some hard five round fights.
You know,
that's a huge advantage.
Especially knowing you've been there,
you know,
the territory as opposed to thatch.
I think that's his biggest
advantage in this fight.
And I don't feel like he's using it.
We're going into round three now.
I mean,
this is right when he,
if you know,
you gotta think John Crouch his coach,
one of the geniuses of MMA.
There's like a handful of geniuses.
It's like Matt Hume for Rasa hobbies.
One of my favorite,
Greg Jackson has a lot of knowledge.
You know,
Ricardo Laborio is a genius of MMA.
There's like these,
these are a few Maestros John
Danaher does a few of them.
John Crouch is one of them.
So when you're agreeing
to fight a kid like this,
he's not dumb.
He knows this kid's a
fucking giant savage.
You know,
there's gotta be some thought
to what the proper strategy is.
And
you know,
the kid is good as anybody and you,
your thoughts are third round,
fourth round.
Fifth round.
Yes.
[inaudible] coach.
I'm saying all right,
now let's start mixing it up.
Grappling,
go for shots where his ass out.
It was clearly lost two rounds though.
Clearly.
Most likely.
Yeah.
I mean in Denver.
And he had double under hooks at one
time when they were transitioning out,
uh,
on a failed spin and he didn't
even try to take him down.
I thought he would have
tried to dump them.
Right.
That's his hometown.
And he felt it and it went away.
Yeah.
But there was like 17 seconds left.
Altitudes short notice.
Yeah.
He went front,
like round kick to the head.
You don't see that that often.
No switch.
I bet you see some take downs.
Got a lot of taekwondo and him as well,
man.
You know,
I mean that was his initial background.
Well the thing is is we've seen
two takedowns both from thatch.
Yup.
And they were ragdoll
takedowns it would take downs.
We expect someone to say bitch.
Yeah,
he thought he dumped them twice.
You know
I liked that right hook to the
body that Benson has been thrown.
It's very interesting to me like Oh shit.
Oh no right hand behind
it got a size advantage.
Oh he's so big.
He's really good at,
I mean I'm going to freak
out if Ben doesn't attempt
to take don and I'm a freak
out and eat this mic.
You got an attempt at man cause
you're getting fucking picked apart.
Do you think he's getting picked apart?
I wouldn't say it that much.
I don't think he's getting picked apart.
Yeah,
but you know what,
man,
I don't think he likes the way it feels
like he feels how strong those hips
already is.
This a abort.
Yeah,
we don't want crazy.
Did it again?
Yeah,
there we go.
Now let's keep her against
the cage is going to be
one 70 bro.
This is one 70 I know,
but you're wearing
thatch out where I'm out.
But look,
look at this though.
This is one seventies this is,
if you're going to win this
exactly what you gotta do,
his savage sheet,
if you don't get it,
that's fine.
Taches and comfortable here.
I guarantee you attaching a slow down.
I'll be listening to Brendan,
Brendan,
shop this.
He's to knows the kid.
Oh,
let's give it up the bag.
Give it up the back and big deep
breaths and now confusion and a loss of
confidence as well.
Right?
And this is Ben's world.
He's a grappler.
This is what he does,
but it's got a crap a little bit.
Come on Henderson when Ben Henderson is
trap the arm.
Dad's got out of it pretty quick though.
But look at,
you know,
he's letting them know like
some shit's going down.
Yeah,
son,
you're my world.
Yeah.
Sweet.
Stand up.
Check this out.
You're in a bad spot here kid.
Hold on to that glove.
He's hit him in the Dick.
Oh,
look at statues.
I man,
look at his right.
You know,
what does
that swollen or is he just,
is it just the angle?
We're looking at it now.
It's slowly.
I mean,
you know how it is if you're
not really a grappler,
you know by nature when
someone has your back,
your heart's fucking a little over
a hundred miles an hour right now.
So even if you don't submit them,
here we are on this fourth round.
You're in trouble,
bro.
Benson's making some,
uh,
some,
some progress with that right arm.
He's moving that right
arm closer and closer.
I mean,
he's,
he's under is under the
armpit with the other one,
but I'm seeing some give,
you know what I'm saying?
You know how when you see a guy started
to pull on the guy's neck and you see
the guy in there.
So I started to give,
he's like,
I see giving,
it's tough.
It's tough with the gloves
man to submitted guy for
even if was body triangle by
triangle do to flatten them out.
Softening up man.
He's got a minute 18 to go.
This fight could be over
right fucking minute.
18 is a long time.
It's a long time dude on your
back and his eye swollen.
We got a good job of defending this long
that tells me he's probably not going
to get them.
This is exhausting.
No match.
He can be very exhausting,
son.
This is the,
this is exciting stuff,
man.
[inaudible] back.
[inaudible]
can I be on fire?
I mean he's,
he knows.
All he has to do to survive
can be resting right here.
Yeah.
It's going to take a lot out of that.
That just never not like
diversity out of them.
You got to realize all that all fetches
wins where first round Kaos that body
triangle.
It looks like his right eye.
It looks like she's riding them.
Both of them.
Both of them are fucked up.
You're right.
They're both fucked up.
He's sneaky side browse though.
Yeah,
I'm not mad.
Oh No.
I a spiderweb.
20 seconds catches up now.
We'll see what he's got smart though.
He had to go for something,
right?
Yeah.
Yup.
This round ends fourth rounds.
Got To fix a ponytail now.
Straight single leg.
If I'm Ben.
Hi as well.
I'm just,
it's loose Eddie,
whatever.
Look at that.
He just wants to stay away.
You have that round to Ben,
right?
Yeah.
He gets it.
He got a two to one going
back and forth to two.
One go on the fourth and the grappling.
Some established that he's
super dominant on the ground.
The only reason why I lost that
position because he went for the arm.
True.
I'll say this.
Who is more tired?
Benson or thatch.
That statue.
I'm saying defending that easy day,
trying to attack the basket.
I'm easy day if you're not a black belt,
if you're a blue belt,
which I,
I would say that just probably
a blue belt on the ground,
but I'm not.
The type for one big
explosion was the arm.
Other than that was just control.
I mean,
when he's tight and when he's under
the armpit and he's across the neck,
there was no commitment.
There was no real crazy
day in the squeeze.
Yeah,
but there's no luck.
Crazy like go,
you know the go for a guillotine.
Hail Mary.
That doesn't work.
The guys arms cash out.
It wasn't none of that.
There was an explosion
to get to spider web,
but I mean that was one big burst.
Yeah.
Other than that it was statue eight more
energy because that's what's trying to
keep that guy off his neck.
He was uncomfortable.
He's got fuck in my hometown and getting
choked Roald Dahl shores flat out with
a body triangle on its back.
Shit got real.
Both eyes are all swollen and shit.
His braids all fucked up out the back.
He didn't fix his ponytail.
I shoot for that single leg if I'm Ben.
Yeah.
Yup.
Now he's thinking about to maybe mix up.
You shoot and hit him with a right hand.
Well,
he also knows that he can
dominate him on do it.
Yeah.
I mean that's just a fact
of standing up so high.
It's still,
he's still got that high kick boxer
stance and that was the reason he got
impatient in that scramble
and wasn't smart defensively.
Wanted to just get back up to his feet
instead of like minus p's and q's and
recognizing he's in a bad spot and that,
that,
that recklessness,
carelessness and trying to get back up
to his feet is where it gave us back.
That comes in grappling experience.
That's just not his background.
Yup.
He just wants to get
the fuck out of there.
It's like,
I don't want to stay in this spot.
Yup.
But in doing so,
he got to a way worst spot,
which is,
you know,
really the essence of Jujitsu,
right.
Capitalizing on mistakes.
Even if that's loses this fight,
he's going to learn so much from this
fight that's going to help him in the
future.
This is because he's
never fought a really,
really good grappler like crazy.
He's gone into deep waters
with a world champion.
This is the best thing for
Thatcher's career to ever happen.
Winter loose.
Yeah.
I agree with you 100% and
it's a smart way to do it too.
To go on a world champion coming
up from a lower weight class.
So you have some advantages going in.
There you go,
Ben.
No.
Keep that hat on the inside.
Not going to happen either way.
This is wearing,
that's out.
I like this sprawl dude.
Sprawl
come up with a flat.
Yeah,
let's make them defend and
then go after it again.
Right?
Yeah.
He's throwing his striking off with those
take down a sloth that just becoming
as stances like he stands so tall.
Nice knee to begin with.
This flow,
that right hand to the body.
Again,
this plan only works if
Ben's Cardio's on point.
Well it's most likely will
be to me it looks like,
I know you guys are,
it looks like fat just as fine
and he's coming forward and he's,
he's definitely not the same fighter.
He wasn't the first two rounds but the
fifth round at altitude you're in Denver
son.
Sorry about it,
but that's what that's going to last
year and the fifth round is going to be
tough.
Mental drains it out to two shows in
our results of Ben's career was spent in
Colorado.
John Crouch started in Denver,
so this is nothing new to Ben.
[inaudible]
timing.
Yeah,
that was beautiful timing.
Stepping over that leg.
Look at.
This is sue my friend.
Oh my friend.
You got along the time.
Arm Triangles.
Common stepping over.
Look at this side control my friend.
Oh that matches back.
Son did the same thing again.
The position didn't like the position.
Oh,
Hookin got that hook in easy.
Doesn't mean he's going to choke him.
No,
he's when the job
he's going to win the round.
Elliot's looking at this
going and making a list.
Going to try to go for
the arm bar again man.
He's going to try to go for the arm bar.
Oh Nice.
Look at this though.
But still I don't like
just being on top man.
I'd rather
get a high level grappler on Ya.
Yeah Dude.
How joke?
Look at this.
Benson transitions easy to the back again.
You see a lot of wrestlers do this.
Turn off forest hand fight and stand up.
Statues a kickboxer.
Let's not do that.
It's a natural thing.
Your natural trying to get back up.
Oh Shit.
Can you get back up?
Oh,
rag,
rag doll and should it be natural though?
You know what I'm saying?
Eddie,
if you're training when the wild though,
this is the world of Benson
Henderson right here.
So
he got this shit
in
his mouth.
He fixed it in the last,
oh my God.
I was like,
I pulled a tooth pick out of
his mouth right after he tapped,
gets so fucked up.
You know he's gonna get
in trouble for that.
They told them not to do that anymore.
No contest.
So crazy.
Fight to the fucking
toothpick in his mouth.
It gets suspended.
He just fought Brent.
That's some Charles Bronson ship.
He just fought Brendan Dash
with a toothpick in it.
So
this,
this is improved bigger
Henderson fan now what?
Because nope,
that too for taking us in July.
That was,
that was awesome.
He didn't shoot.
Look how he finished it.
Look at the way you finished it.
You just see sort of,
but it's kind of like this,
like I said,
domain.
Either way.
Brandon's gonna learn a ton from this.
This is best case scenario.
He wins either way,
it goes up to one set.
Dan Severn isn't just about,
he's what with the legs are doing.
Squeeze that down.
It's a oxymoron.
Actually.
Dan's fancy.
He's a bad motherfucker.
He's,
he's world class man.
He's world class.
He fucked up that tooth.
Picto dude did.
She can't keep doing that man.
Can't keep doing that
fat
head kicked.
It's not the problem.
Like the athletic commissions can get in
trouble if it turns out that toothpick
comes out and poke somebody in
the eye and some strange world.
We're Benson's on top,
he gets hit with an
upkick pick comes down,
goes into the guy's eyeball.
The Guy who's doing pds
fight in an APP to fight.
Be Like,
oh,
he was on beat was on,
on the podcast.
It's called hold on.
Is that,
is that what happened?
Did they know the test
results before the fight?
They knew about uh,
Jon Jones,
but that's coke.
Okay.
Still petition.
It's not a performance enhancing drug.
I think if they knew that
Anderson tested positive before,
it's way more damning than if
they knew that John Jones did.
They knew that Jon Jones,
Johns Johns is doing something
that's going to ruin the chances.
What about if you're doing coke?
Could just study youtube videos.
That's maybe Coco throw a
thousand spinning kicks.
Yeah,
exactly.
You know what I'm saying?
A lot of good points here.
Got a good point.
Everyone is making it so said that
y'all aren't going to learn that.
What y'all are like,
y'all aren't going to learn anything.
I don't know.
Matt's room with these two spaces,
the least of our worries.
Hey Commission.
Oh we get those results back in time.
The toothpick.
That is good.
But God damn old,
he can't,
he can't fight with the fucking
toothpick in your mouth.
You just can't.
It's so crazy when when he stepped
out and then pull the toothpick,
he's like flaunting it.
I liked it.
He steps out.
He's got the to pick out right away
cause he's like Scott and rock dude that,
so he had a
toothpick in his mouth when pet his head
kicked him and dropped a and that was
the side that he tucks it.
I think we'd more dangerous for himself.
Right.
It's very dangerous for him.
Choke on toothpicks,
get like worn out over time.
They get all like bro Man,
he must have like,
you know what I'm saying?
He's got a weird way.
Just get a weird way of talking
to that thing in his mouth.
Yeah,
that shit is soft as hell.
That's like paper.
Okay.
I'll remember that.
Look beds and it sends
a bad mother fucker.
That was a huge victory.
He essentially fought your game plan.
What you thought he should do that?
I mean that's really what he did.
He hung with them on the feet for the
first round last probably the first and
second round and then took
them into some deep water.
That's just a funny guy.
I hope they interview
on.
That's exactly what he did.
Type movie.
Fuck it dude.
Stack up to some of the
championship.
The toothpaste philosophy lesson
so crazy with dropping knowledge.
Keep Up.
We drop knowledge.
Yeah.
When you stare across the
octagon at that fucking psycho,
you might want to rethink that.
Got 170 [inaudible] the Canadian psycho.
I mean there's a big difference.
She stepping up till like the number
arguably number to welterweight in the
world.
Then you give Roy a title shot,
man.
Yeah.
Don't make him fight hectare.
Roided out.
Heck,
there's not going to
fight for a long time now,
but a Goddamn Benson Henderson is a bad
motherfucker to step up like that and
say he wants to fight Rory
Macdonald after that fight.
He Benson is a bad motherfucker,
dude.
He's so good.
Yeah.
That turns a long career ahead of them.
This is great learning spot.
That layoff,
right?
Yeah.
Well he had some injuries,
right?
Satch threw a kick in practice
and it hit the kid's face.
It might've been Matt
Brown hit Mack Brown's face
compound fractured his big toe
compound fractures.
So the fucking through the
skin bones out of the skin.
Yeah.
That's why he was out for so long.
Oh,
that's what happened.
Jesus Christ.
Oh,
I saw the picture that there
was like a picture of it online.
[inaudible] did that
for that Dude Benson's bad ass.
Can you imagine him?
Roy needs a fight too.
That would be amazing.
That'd be amazing.
I just get a title shot
with a Quarry Hill.
Well,
this podcast is over.
This is a huge win for Benson Henderson.
That was fucking tremendous.
I'm so impressed with this dude.
So impressed with him.
He's a beast.
So I mean that was such a hard fight to,
uh,
that's it for the podcast.
Eddie Bravo.
What's up next?
Ebi Three March 22nd
he bravo invitational.
March 20th at where
can people information?
Eddie Bravo,
invitational.com it's at
the Orpheum downtown La.
Justin Myles.
What's your website again?
Www that jam.
Don't ever say www.
Janet personal training.com.
He's TTP.
Coldly.
Slash slash.
Jam.
Personal trait.
Yeah.
Jam Jam.
Personal trainer.
Very good dude.
Justin Milo's kill a bee.
We're going to see you
throw one down in Brazil.
They're local son.
Eric Silva.
What's the date again?
March 21st March 21st
live on Fox sports one,
right?
Yup.
The Bam tape.
Motherfucking Fletcher CEO and
pirate and chief of caveman coffee.
That's it.
I don't know.
He might come up with
some concrete cowboys.
Dallas,
Austin,
Houston would open in
Houston in two months.
Right now.
Door does.
Trying to kind of stay ahead then
because know Brendan motherfucking job,
you can listen to them every
week at least twice a week.
Do you guys do twice a week fighter?
And the kid podcast with
my brother Brian Cowen,
available on line and
many different forms.
You guys have like a
video version of iTunes,
everything.
It's available.
It's fantastic.
You'll love it.
And you can follow him
on Twitter and Instagram.
Brendan Schaub on both of those,
right?
Are In to shop and uh,
that's it.
You fucks.
All right.
Thanks everybody.
Another,
uh,
fight companion podcast and the
book would take care of you guys.